[Music]
well hey everybody what's going on it's
September 1st why are you getting out of
you're going into the next person's
video again look at the [__] camera's
all [__] up it's not [__] up yeah it
is it's not centered well yeah because
the when it was centered it looked
really weird I'll fix it well you
weren't in here see I'll fix it that's
what happens there you
go that's a lot better all right yeah
it's better well hey everybody what's
going on like I said yeah we're just
getting just getting ready just getting
the show ready I mean you know I've been
in here before but you know you weren't
see she's mad at me cuz I she cuz I
wasn't in here well you never come in
here like early enough to all right now
we got like all these wires perect we
got wires and [__] hanging in the
[__] your fault no it's not my fault
that's your fault how's that my fault I
don't know cuz everything's your fault I
didn't have do that neither did [__]
with me neither did I this those little
ring lights and everything everything's
dangling everything's dangling well
we're not going to turn that on you know
I said you got that one there I forgot
about that one well yeah I don't there's
one on the camera too but I don't we
don't turn that one on cuz then it's
like way too
bright so yeah so hey everybody what's
going on it's Friday night it's Friday
and Jen finally finished her job
that's it I'm free that was her last day
yeah yep so we're fulltime I'm so
excited fulltime full-time hose now
we're
in fulltime H we were we were full-time
internet before it's just that you know
open up opening up the new business
we're going to start hammering away on
that probably tomorrow night maybe a
little bit Sunday get certain things set
up set the set the Twitter up link tree
and [__] like that get all that going
then I'm have my porn friends [__]
pour all their
[__] all their [__] friend
connections and [__] through Twitter
what do they call them uh what do they
call it contacts yeah yeah so we can
become internet Superstars well yeah
we'll see I hope so we're GNA see yeah I
mean I think we're going to do good like
I said as long as I make enough money to
live on like as much as I was making
before it'll happen then I'll be happy
because you also all your other little
side gigs yeah I mean yeah you'll have
more money for that or more time for
that
yeah that's another thing because I do
have like freelance work that I'm kind
of always rushing to finish because we
did we did the the numbers you could
actually make what was it $300 a month
less and still Break Even yeah cuz
that's how much I was spending in gas
that's what the gas was going over there
$300 a month in gas to commute to that
[__] yeah far tearing that car
up well honestly car what I thought I
was you know that car is a hero I have
to say yeah she's very old full for
Taurus she's almost 20 years old yeah
and all this week I was kind of like
nervous about it cuz I said it would be
just my [__] luck for this to be this
cuz when I was driving home I said I'm
not going to be excited about this being
my last day until I get home because I
said it would be just my [__] luck to
be on the last day of Friday and I W and
I'm going home and like the car breaks
down or it won't start or something like
that but no it was fine remind me this
weekend go down there and test that
battery that battery's
overdue yeah I know but uh and batteries
are [__] gone up quite a bit yeah and
I'm not going to um I'm not going to buy
that new motorcycle tire I'm just going
to pull that tire off there and Patch it
from the from within okay but please be
careful like when you're riding that
around yeah well that's the one I don't
ride as fast that's that's the 1,000
okay well I don't I don't I don't know
how fast you're going out on on the road
that's just my street bike I'm sure
you're not telling me the [__] race
bike he's sneaking around behind like
going 100 miles an hour down to the
Oasis yeah or wherever it is I'm not
going that fast that's just I'm just
going to legal legal Street speeds
mostly okay well that's good very rarely
do I go over 70 or 80 on the uh on the
xp9 yeah okay that's fair enough that's
about how fast I drive which is way over
the speed but hey the acceleration is
faster I get up there a lot quicker I'm
just boom you know what I mean but [__]
it I don't want to lose my license holy
[__] man like when I was coming home
today like I was on 44 and there was a
guy on a motorcycle SL scooter kind of I
guess he'd been to the store cuz he had
a bag like over his arm that [__] was
going like 35 miles an hour I finally
had a bag over his arm yeah we like a
you know like a like a plastic bag like
why because man I've done that before it
fills up with air like a [__]
parachute and it'll rip off your arm
well there was stuff yeah yeah there was
stuff in it like it rip the plastic and
it'll go flying off your arm so he's
trying to go as slow as he can cuz if he
gets in the air in there it'll it'll F
pull off his arm I to go around him
though cuz I'm like I'm like yo I'm not
going 35 miles an hour all the way home
absolutely not he was he evidently it
was something he couldn't stuffed down
his
jacket yeah I guess I couldn't see what
it was in yeah it just [__] to start
stretching the [__] plastic and boom
and all your [__] goes everywhere had it
happen oh yeah oh yeah and stop [__] not
not recently yeah that just a mistake I
made a long time ago you can't I guess
it only happens one time and then you
learn yeah and you learn yeah you can't
just [__] put your arm through the
[__] holes in the plastic bag and
ride it'll [__] tear it right off
yeah October 8 says I'm getting new le
leather lace up pants hell yeah just
like Jim Morrison October wraith October
yeah it's a guy well haven't haven't
seen you in a long time and dermit is
here too I Haven haven't seen dermit in
a long time a long time yeah so hey
everybody welcome sexy as leather pants
man sexy ass leather pants yeah they
start to form to your body I've had a
pair of them before they they eventually
[__] start ripping at the [__]
crotch I was going to say I thought you
were going to say they eventually start
standing up on their own
no like in your shape eventually start
they eventually start [__] um at
least the pair that I had they start
getting eaten out around the crotch just
rips in opportune time there's there's
no way to [__] fix it you could
probably you could probably sew it but
you'd have to sew a big ass patch you
know and I was [__] in my 20s I was
like I [__] it I just threw the digs
away yeah well somebody gave them to me
anyway yeah October 8 said I'm still
building my bike and yes I'm a guy okay
okay what kind of bike is he building I
don't know for I don't
know YP PO said get him a Flintstones
bike foot power Granite Granite
Wheels we can't go that Oracle says I
have good news we got the the uh path
report back on my husband's second
biopsy they got everything out and the
verdict is benign oh good that's good at
least I mean you know you deserve have
some good news for Christ's sake out of
all the [__] that happened Mark says the
rock and roll show you guys did recently
was excellent well thank you very much
oh thanks yeah that was a good that was
a good time fun yeah i' I've actually
really liked I mean I usually really
like all the topics that we do or I
wouldn't do them but yeah the last
couple topics we've done like the last
show that we did about the made in the
Iron Mask and The Rock and Roll mystery
one I I don't know I had a lot of I had
a lot of fun doing those had a lot of
fun doing those yeah Zach says yeah you
get leather pants and they're nice until
you have to peel yourself out of them
with a spatula and lots of
[Laughter]
soap I don't think I've ever owned a
pair of leather pants I would ever like
afford
them I've had like some fake leather
pants they look good they look real good
[__] but the they've got to be pretty
tight and when they're tight they they
they're going to start they're going to
split eventually if they're too baggy
like lot of the motorcycle ones are
baggy on purpose because you need some
give in of you know me right but if you
want to look like a rockar like Jeff
Morrison that [__] has got to be tight
yeah that's like like old [__] old
mle crew [__] Le pants off the
[__] Too Fast for Love
album they got to see the Bulge yeah
they didn't have zippers they had it
down lace like on a [__] front of a
shoe where your dick is you just pull
it yeah cuz it was less there's less uh
less chance of failure on something like
that just eyelets and a
[__] you know what I mean a string
yeah well like I said it's kind of nice
as sort of like adjustable yeah you know
and they were Lac down the S side so you
can adjust how tight they
were yeah YP post said leather pants
killed Jim Morrison only way he could
hit those high notes though I'd be
screaming too sure and [__] boy
man [__] evidently Jim Morrison's
pants stuck stunk a high habit man you
never wash them things filled with
bacteria that's pretty gross you can
wear it almost indefinitely because it
kind of breathes like skin you can but
should you that's the larger
question Zach says Jenny writing
question okay what do you do when coming
up with good dialogue I kind of act the
scenes out and talk to myself as the
characters when I write I kind of do
that too um I'll write stuff just kind
of like out of my head but then when I
go back I'll read it out out loud so
that you know so I'm making sure that it
doesn't sound [__] up you know what I
mean I was like well does that sound
like something a person would actually
say or you know what I mean because I've
read a lot of books where the dialogue
was strange it shouldn't call attention
to itself I mean you shouldn't be
thinking about it I don't remember what
book it was and I think I did a video on
it a while back but the like the book
overall was good but the dialogue in
there was so weird like the guy like the
the author didn't use any contractions
hardly and most of the characters were
like teenage boys and I'm like teenage
boys don't talk like I will not do that
they don't talk like that and it was
just and it was very very jarring so it
kept like kind of like pulling me out of
the story and I'm just like I wonder why
that was allowed to fly I don't really
it's very weird it was just really weird
it was like a weird decision like I said
it was a good story and it was like good
otherwise but I just thought that was
bizarre all right October wraith said
that he was building a Yamaha 650
XS pandemonium style
bobber I think the I think the Yamaha
650 was kind of like the 650 XL back in
the day which was I think something kind
of based like a Triumph I I think I
think it's the same bike he's talking
about the ex okay like that one movie
that had uh like the first movie that
had U The Wolverine in it you know that
that liveaction Wolverine movie he had a
Yamaha exit cell I think it was maybe
late 70s early ' 80s he had one all beat
up one on the back of his
camper they were hard to find back then
so I um but they were they were
basically
a the Bonville basically um somebody had
told me that the original XL was
actually a tri Bonville that Yamaha when
Triumph went out of
business Triumph sold the [__]
blueprints to that to the new Bonville
to Yamaha and they they released it as a
Yamaha XL but it was actually on paper
originally a Triumph like a an improved
version of a bottle bill that maybe the
bike he's talking about or a later
version of
that October WTH also says I'm kind of
fat but you must have leather lace up
pants um YP PO said you could write a
Horror Story about saltwater leather old
school torture method and somebody uh I
think Camp guy said that um Ed gain
wouldn't know how to take care of
leather pants
yeah I was just thinking about old Ed G
the other day because I was rereading
the um remember when we watched that
movie deranged from
1974 I want to say or 73 when did that
movie come out it was early 70s and
remember it was the one the actually at
the time that was um the most it was a
fictional movie obviously but it was the
most accurate to the Ed G crimes
although they did kind of like it's
pretty gory and [__] up and everything
like that but they did kind of like uh
tone it down a little bit they didn't
have you know like he had like some
bowls made out of skulls and [__] like
that but he didn't have like they didn't
find the box of volvas or anything like
they did in real life didn't he have a
box of volas edge no he just had a box
of damn [__] well that's what I said
it was a box of volvas I thought that
was okay that's the outside okay that's
the outside of the [__] that's the
outside of it or yeah you didn't know
that
at first I thought you were talking
about the
car he had a box full of Volvos he was
like what like oh okay yeah oh my God
that's what I'm going to start calling
mine from now on yeah EV Volvo yeah
that's
of well because if you say like and I
think a lot of people maybe don't even
know this but it's like if you say
vagina that's not like the outside
that's the inside part yeah the Vol is
the outside yeah guys don't care we just
trying to get in it well I they don't
care I'm just saying words mean things
yeah words mean
things but um Zach says actually Jen
have you ever written a story with a
serial killer in it that might be real
cool um I have written well there's at
least one that I'm coming up with just
I've written so many stories but there
is one that I have come up with uh a
long time ago that had a serial killer
in it but it was almost kind of like
there was a serial killer but then there
was also kind of like a supernatural
kind of [__] going on like on the other
side of it like I don't know I don't
want to give too much away but yeah I
have done at least one with a serial
killer he was kind I can't remember what
he was called it was a long time ago
that I read it but I can't remember what
he was called he had some kind of like
animal thing that he did like like a
trademark that he left on the victims
and
stuff box a peas what the [__] yeah I
mean Ed G had well and didn't he have
like the nipple belt too yeah I know he
had
nipple and a and a box of all those he
had he had a lady suit he had a face
yeah he had somebody's I think I don't
remember whose face it was he had a lady
face that he used as a
mask I mean did he ever take any living
people to see that stuff while he was
alive before he killed him I don't think
so he killed him remotely didn't he and
then just brought him there dead I don't
think he got brought anybody alive there
well what about that one woman that he
took out and the barn and like butchered
like a she was dead I think when he got
her there isn't that the one he shot oh
maybe he shot her when she was at work
and put her in his put her in his that's
right and then took her there I don't
think he took anybody alive there nobody
knew I can you imagine like taking the
date over there like I want to show you
like he might have been crazy but he
wasn't so crazy he knew his place look
like [__] he didn't want anybody to see
how how [__] up it looked inside that
house yeah B yeah Ben said he shot at
her shop that's right I forgot about
that cuz didn't he kill he killed what
two three something like that yeah cuz
most of like most of the [__] up two I
think it was only two but like most of
the [__] up [__] they found in his
house was like stuff that he dug out
of I mean which you know that's not good
either it's easy to get a girlfriend
that
way yeah just go out of cemetery dig one
up you got your pick yeah oh my God
we're already going to get funny is he
liked the old ones like the old fat
ones you know it gu more comfortable
every everybody has a type his tight
yeah that was better than that Russian
dude digging up all those dead little
girls and then dressing them up as dolls
Oh that was so weird we yeah we did a
show about that didn't we yeah he
thought he was saving him from the
ground I think we did a show about was
that the same show that we did that
weirdo like the I think was from Florida
that that woman that he was in love with
died and then like he stole her body and
yeah yeah made kept it in his house made
a fake vagina made a fake badge for and
everything he was having sex with it
yeah that weird dude he knew when she
was alive when she died went down and
got her yeah I mean he didn't kill
anybody but
still no and matter of fact the dude
that dug up all the little girls over in
rush I don't think he was even he wasn't
molesting them either he was digging
them up dead we know of yeah have you
seen there wasn't there wasn't any signs
that and and like his parents saw them
and thought that they were handmade
dolls yeah he couldn't see the faces
they were all wrapped up yeah cuz he
wrapped up in like little coats and hats
and [__] like that I me all dressed up
they I saw photographs of them
he had about six or seven of
them he said he couldn't bear to leave
them in the
ground yeah which okay he had some
mental problems he said he could hear
him call call calling and crying and
stuff yeah he had some issues yeah I
mean you know Tammy said I just watched
the last Voyage of the demer loved it
question do you think there will be a
part two I hope so because they kind of
did set it up for that but it didn't do
as well as they were expecting so I
imagine probably not
unfortunately but yeah they could have
set that up as like a whole [__]
series man cuz like I don't know like
Universal some of the movies that
they've done in their quote unquote Dark
Universe it's like they keep trying to
like get it started but it's like it
seems like they're not real they just
can't get it off the ground man they
don't have any consistency yeah they
can't stick to anything yeah and it's
like some of the movies individually are
good like I said like I really liked
last wood the demeanor I really liked
invisible man that came out a few years
ago ago um but you know some of them
were just like not good and they didn't
really think it through I guess all of
those studios are
collapsing just I've been seeing [__] on
it like their stocks [__] Disney
stock is just [__] plummeted because
people are and then they think that it's
artificially inflated because uh they're
lying about how much money that they're
losing on all this streaming [__] I
don't think Disney's going to survive I
mean you know that's just not me pulling
out of my ass there financially just
[__]
up and they did it because they bought
all that damn [__] all that damn
[__] all those properties and all
that streaming [__] and sunk all that
money into shitty Star Wars that wasn't
good Star Wars the only good Star Wars
they had was [__] the first two
seasons of the
mandalorean because and you know
remember our friend was right the guy
who worked for Disney Tracy's husband
Tracy's
ex-husband I remember when they bought
that property he worked for Disney he
doesn't win anym though though he worked
at he actually was a mechanic though he
worked at the park and he knew that he
knew that company real
well and uh when they bought that I was
jacked I says man they got a lot of
money they probably make great he's like
no he no he you don't know this company
they're going to ruin that [__] Force
awakens came out I thought it was okay
but then the second one and the third
one is like Noah and then all the
[__] I was turned off by that [__]
although somebody sent me a DVD of the
mandalorean or Blu-ray bootleg Blu-ray
of the [__] mandalorean that sh was
[__] top-notch quality a viewer sent
it me I forgot who it was though if drop
it in the comment section if uh well I
thought somebody also gave us their
Disney plus and password look at the the
second season yeah and man I was like
yeah the Mandalorian the first couple
Seasons like man this is it but then
Disney politically started falling apart
because through all this infighting
between all these [__] people trying
to trying to run the Star Wars [__]
section man that [__] but well like I
said I mean I already have Hulu and I
think they have a bundle deal now where
you for like a couple more bucks you can
get Disney plus too but don't bother but
you know but like I said I'm already
paying like nine bucks for a Hulu so
don't bother if there's anything on
there want to
watch because there well yeah but there
might be stuff I want to watch evidently
a lot of the good shit's not on there
anymore um they they they they're in
these [__] up weird licensing
agreements with other platforms that
just and then they just backed out of a
a day with another platform and the
people that paid for it through that
other platform say Hey where's all the
Disney [__] that I paid for and just you
know Disney's falling
apart um but Tracy's ex-husband was
right he says they he says he knows them
how they do things and how they think he
just say says they will [__] Star Wars
up Ben's telling us some Edge
jokes the sheriff told Ed G he would get
the chair have a heart he
replied Ed G's been helping to win the
Vietnam War by shipping them arms so
there's nice that's nice uh Zach says
the two True Crime cases that still [__]
me up to this day are Nora Fuller yeah
that is a very [__] up case and the
family murders in Australia yeah those
are bad I think we've I don't know if we
did a show about Nora Fuller but I wrote
about her in my uh faceless villain book
but I'm pretty sure we did a show about
the family murders that was that what's
that dude's name um [__] it's right on
the [__] tip of my tongue and I was
just thinking about it the other day too
because I was going back through my
books and reading about
it what was his [__] name God damn it
it'll probably come to me like [__]
10 minutes from now and then I'll be
like
yeah um let's
see Ed Gan took got your nose way too
literally Ben says Adelaide is not a
good place to visit yeah you said you
had that weird
German Dutch name yeah it was like
[__] God damn it what the hell was
it's right on the damn tip of my tongue
but I can't think of it yeah Zach says
Nora Fuller would make a really good
movie if you ask me the details of it
are just so damn creepy yeah I do kind
of remember like a little bit of the um
details around that case and I'm
surprised it's not better known Zach
says also a show suggestion Princess
Diana death conspiracies yeah that might
be interesting let me well wait do I
have a pen October says I know something
I'm intelligent but I don't know what it
is you're refering to like can you like
hand me that like a piece of paper and a
pen where it's just there's like
wherever there's tons of paper and [__]
like that over there I just didn't bring
it over here with me I will write that
down and put it in the next poll
princess die
conspiracies yeah cuz that's one that I
probably wouldn't have thought
of okay
oh yeah Muhammad Al had passed away
yeah um Camp guy weirdest for me would
be that gal that lived in a box under
that dude's bed voluntarily for like
seven years or more yeah you know what I
was just listening to um one of those
like creepy story compilations cuz I
like to listen to them while I drive and
they were talking about that it wasn't
really voluntarily well yeah I mean she
just got like St like St all syndrome
like Stockholm Syndrome they grabbed her
when she was a little kid basically
think she's 17 or 16 or something and
they just terrified her and the dude was
that dude was vicious man he do like
these [__] vicious tortures and stuff
and it just broke her and then she ended
up falling in love with the guy but he
just put a box on her head that had a
big it was all [__] she said it was
super hot you could barely breathe on it
through it and he'd have that box on her
head for days you know [__] and then
um uh just do stuff to her you know the
first one he captured he killed
accidentally trying to cut her vocal
cords out cuz she was screaming too much
he didn't want her screaming when he was
doing this [__] to her and his
girlfriend helped him his girlfriend was
another one that had a Stockholm Centrum
she helped him abduct both of those
girls yeah but um and you looked at the
dude and he's
just look like a [__] beta you know
what I mean just well they all kind of
look like that other other than like the
only ones that can think of that were
actually like goodlooking or normal
looking like as far as that goes were
the Ken and Barbie Killers yeah Paul
Bernardo and that other bitch's name
yeah there was something up with them s
sadist some kind it was more like a
Thrill Kill too yeah that was [__] we
did yeah I think we talked about them on
like one of our [__] up Valentine's
Day shows where we always do killer
couples yeah but um Carla hula that was
her name car Hoka they let her out
didn't they yeah yeah she they gave her
a slap on her wrist she went to some
kind of
damn what it was like a minimum security
yeah um lesbian vacation resort
basically and laying out there in the
bikini with her friends there V there
was a [__]
photograph that smuggled out of there
somebody took a picture of her in a
bikini laying out out in the [__]
yard the prison
yard with her girlfriend she had a
girlfriend in there that uh she wasn't
in there for very long it's cuz she
rolled over and ratted on her boyfriend
but she killed some of them girls too
she just said well I was scared yeah
right well wasn't that the one where she
actually like offered up her sister yeah
yeah to him and they killed the sister
there was an accident that he killed the
sister but she offered him up to [__]
for sex yeah and she was like what 14 15
yeah yeah they drugged her and knocked
her out the drugs killed her yeah it's
[__] up so she she deserved to die but
this is Canada they're soft up I mean he
got in trouble but it's like I don't
know I kind of feel like maybe they
thought take both
out I mean just that I can't even
imagine I can't imagine where you would
get to a place in your life where you
would think that any of that was like
remotely okay you got so wrong at that
point you got to go just saying you know
that's just how it is that's the thing
is and we've talked about this before
like I'm not a big proponent of the
death penalty or anything that but it's
just kind of like people like that I'm
not really sure it can be
fixed once you've gone that far in that
direction I'm just I don't think they
can fix it the problem is with the
American system is they spend too much
money on it and too much
time when they know that you've done
it and they sentence you to death the
appeal should be quick you know what I
mean and it should be just
procedural and then when it's
uh when you lose your appeal they just
kill you right then they just take you
out back and shoot you there's none of
this big like China that's how China
does it there's no big we're going to
spend $7 million in 14 years you know
what I mean [__] sentences due to
death n [__]
that yeah there's going to be a an error
rate that's with everything you're
dealing with the government they don't
care you know but usually you know I I
would say that they'd have to know you
know there's just too much
evidence yeah I mean if they were sure
yeah they guys got sure like I said
there has to be at least [__] DNA
evidence for sure well I'm talking about
guys like Bundy you know yeah like I
said it would just be like super extreme
cases like if there's mitigating factors
then no but it's just like yeah somebody
like Ted Bundy and or people like that
that just did the most [__] up [__]
imaginable and didn't feel bad or don't
seem capable of feeling bad well you
know it's not just [__] like that you
hold up a store and you [__] execute
the damn employees no you should die
you know you go in to go rob a damn
7-Eleven you got a minimum wage worker
you shoot the dude for no reason it's
not even his money yeah is just because
you don't want to be identified yeah you
got to die wear a [__] mask then yeah
Pro tip Zach says oh fun fact I learned
it's both Barry Gibb's birthday and his
wedding anniversary today Zach has a big
crush on Barry Gibb you
guys it's his hair it's that fabulous
hair
yeah that hair is gay as hell
it's it's retroactively gay it's pulling
him back into another time to be gay
he's being gay in the past if Victor was
here he would say that he would say that
Barry Gibbs hair made yeah Victor would
say yeah Barry Gibbs hair made me good
before I was born back in 197 1970 yeah
yeah that's how that works
1976 yeah uh the gay gene reaching
backwards of
time grabbing you making you gay from
the
past
it's like a gay Time
Warp let's do the gay time warp again
they made a whole movie about the gay
Time Warp they did you just reminded me
of
it we know the
butler huh good friends with the Butler
from that movie which one yeah Dr um oh
right right yeah yeah you know riff ra
yeah riff ra not the actual Riff Raff
but you know what I mean our version of
Riff somebody kind of looked like riff
Isabella said did did you watch Snow
toown yes I did um if you're not into
like real [__] up depressing movies
probably give it a pass it was really
good but not a good time yeah it's about
the murders good movie but I wouldn't
recommend it to anyone yeah same um and
then Ben says yeah snow toown wasn't
about the family murders different
murder ring family murders was
homosexuals killing young men Snowtown
was young men killing homosexuals yeah
it was two different things YP PO said
rib cage necklace yeah I got my rib cage
necklace on today Wednesday Adams says
is a
lightweight I guess what is it what she
didn't have a necklace did she at least
on the original show on the original
show she always wore the same dress yeah
like on the Netflix series they put
different outfits on her but yeah I
guess because it was based on the comic
and she always had the same little dress
on yeah it's actually a comic strip yeah
it was a comic strip yeah like they
drove all the same they were just icons
kind of yeah yeah exact same I have a
book of um of the
original uh Comics they were kind of
panel Comics actually I don't knowed
gory type yeah I mean Edward gory stuff
is a lot more
elaborate and a lot more
surrealist I will say that um but I
don't know I like them both so I love Ed
rori by the way he's one of he's my
favorite I have a bunch of books of his
stuff too his stuff was like super
weird
but I love it that Edward gory got
pretty popular I mean he had really a
whole
career out of the stuff that he drew and
if you read some of his stuff it's like
the weirdest [__] [__] of vet all
that would never happen I mean I feel
like that would never happen like
something that especially back then but
I guess it was original like nobody
really was doing anything like that
actually matter of fact right over there
I have a big um ni a big print of uh the
gashly crumb tinies which if you haven't
seen it is
um it's like an illustrated poem about
children dying in horrible ways and it
Rhymes it's really cool but yeah and
that's actually the second one I had
because I had one before and it got all
[__] up so I had to buy another one
because I liked it so much
but let's see
um talking about Barber strand because
he had Barry Gibb on there time travel
makes you gay sure I guess it could yeah
he was talking about Rocky Horror but I
was confused because I was like we don't
know the actual Riff Raff what are you
talking about
um Zach says I've learned that if you
put a charismatic good-looking man in
front of me and have him talk about
interesting [__] I'm putty in your
hands that's good to know Zach we might
need to use that information against you
at some point we never would I'm just
kidding it'd be so easy to get me to
join a cult and I don't like it
oh no well I mean at least you're aware
of it so maybe that would like maybe
that would keep it from happening but
looks like my hair is like caught on my
glasses I don't think I could ever I
mean I don't you know you can't ever say
never I mean it would depend on how
people came at me with it but I don't
think I could ever get anybody could
ever get me to join a cult CU I'm not a
joiner I don't even like to join groups
of like [__] that I like you know what I
mean like the minute somebody says hey
do you want to join join this and I'm
just like no no I don't want to join
anything thank you I just I'm not I
don't know I don't like that I don't
like people that much so I guess that's
probably
why oh my God okay uh yeah October said
necklace looks cool thank you very much
yeah I got it on uh I just got it on
Sheen I think it was like $2 you
know I think it was $2 uh Ben said gory
stuff was in newspaper comic originally
wasn't it I'm not real sure I know
Charles Adams stuff was because like I
said I think his was like a panel comic
it wasn't like a comic strip um Edward
gory he started out as a commercial
artist and an illustrator because I
first saw his
stuff um in when he was like
illustrating people's books like ya
novels like um he Illustrated the
original publication of John B's the
house with the clock in its walls which
is one of my favorite books when I was
growing up and I think that was the
first time that i' had seen his artwork
it was either that or you remember that
PBS show called mystery and the
animation at the beginning like Edward
gory drew that so I used to see that
when I was a kid too cuz I saw it like a
lot all the time in PBS in the 70s and I
think that was so it was either one of
those two things but then so he
Illustrated a lot of books but then I
found out later that he had written his
own little books that were usually like
poems and then he Illustrated those as
well like he would just have these
little books that came out with little
stories on them Ben said the time travel
makes you gay yeah it's got me thinking
man about Doctor
Who yeah yeah what's your theory uh as
far as that goes what happens when you
have when you just [__] live
traveling through time do you flip gay
and straight and gay and straight every
time you time travel it flips you over
so like in do so in some of the episodes
[__] the doctor is straight in other
episodes doctor's gay but he's in the
closet see you don't know so yeah just
have my mind was working so what would
it be like if that would actually happen
if that was actually written in the
script imagine
that yeah okay okay well I mean it was
okay I'm not like a I'm not real up on
my doctor who lore because like you
watched it the Tom Baker ones like a lot
more than I the only Doctor Who because
you have Brit box yeah he's the only
Doctor Who and see I mean there's been a
lot of them but yeah I I liked
Christopher eckleson but I didn't see
all them he's right but um
I thought is he he's not even a person
is he really or he's not like a human
technically he's not a human yeah that's
G that's right he's a Time Lord yeah I
knew he was a Time Lord but I wasn't
sure what that a whole race of them he
stole that Tardis it didn't work it was
broken that's why that's why it always
looked like a police box it couldn't
change it's supposed to change to fit
the to fit the uh the environment but he
stole it from um from a repair center
he was on the run from something I
forgot what it was and I think he was
young for a Time Lord he's like their
version of a
teenager because they could they could I
guess they were damn near Immortal
because they would rejuvenate they died
they come back to somebody else that's
how they explain cast
changes see that was a brilliant idea
yeah you regenerate turn something into
somebody else
sure Zach says Tom I'm sure Doctor Who
fanfiction has all the answers to your
question man there's star there's Star
Trek fan fiction where um of course Kirk
and Spock are getting it on they even
got [__] drawings and [__] friend of
mine went friend of mine [__] had it
in a textbook back in the his college
textbook back in the 90s when he was
going to college he was in some kind of
there was something about literature and
they just showed it as a sample about
what fanfiction was that was something
else when you had to go to college to
know what fanfiction was well yeah I
mean it was a different time pre-
internet yeah
yeah that's it's just funny to think
about because yeah people have been
writing it ever since there's been [__]
to write about Y and they probably been
writing dirty versions of everything
since it was sh write about I'm going
you know one of these days I don't
really have any time and I don't I'm
interested but not that interested you
know what I mean like interested enough
to go look at like the the Kirk and
that's really geeky [__] that's okay I'm
I'm I'm geeky I'm not I'm not I'm not
ashamed of it I think well you know
women would probably be into that well
like I said because it's because it's
written yeah um dudes have it but
they're making like virtual reality 3D
porn of known of known like video game
characters yeah there's a lot of that
lots of that yeah some of it's [__]
well edited turn it into music videos
and
[__]
eventually eventually [__] uh AI will
be able to just [__] make fantastic
[__] porn out of nothing impossible
body
shapes furry porn they had all that [__]
Fooda porn yeah they got all of that
just yeah but I think there's and some
of that [__] looks like I mean it puts
Pixar to shame it looks like they're
using the same software that like Pixar
would work that's why some of a lot of
these movie companies are in so much
trouble you know [__] they're like
yeah my son makes those you know that
kind of [__] he can make he can make
that same [__] cartoon yeah
[__] computers are another joke well
and everybody you can make stuff to your
own specifications like you can make
stuff that you like so yeah you know
what I mean so if the writing isn't
superb if it's not really a good
time you know there's some people you
know and you know there's going to be
movies but there I think there's going
to be fewer of them and they're going to
be
cheaper Ken Higgin said Cults can only
prey on people who actively want to be a
part of something no matter what it is
so not liking people could save you see
that's what I always thought because I
have never absolutely never felt the
need to be a part of anything in fact I
actively avoid it so I just don't think
they could get me unless they came out
it real roundabout all scient EX
Scientologist cult members all say well
I just joined because I wanted to help
out I'm trying to help the world and
just like you [__] fool like you
you're arrogant enough to think you
you can [__] clear the planet just
ridiculous that's what I mean it's just
very and particularly Scientology and I
know we pick on Scientology a lot but
that's just because we know the most
about them because like I said I used to
work with a bunch of scientologists and
it was a horrifying experience and you
know and then subsequently researched it
a lot but that's kind of the thing is
there's such and I guess this is kind of
true of most Cults and most religions is
there's definitely an aspect of
narcissism you'd have to be a narcissist
oh I I could help the planet yeah I'm
going to save the
planet yeah just the planet doesn't want
your [__] savings you know what I
mean there people making money off the
way it being [__] up you know they
kill you to stop you from saying well
the thing about it is that really all
you can do it's like you know just do
little [__] that's that's good you know
what I mean your family just help your
or you know get throw throw a couple
bucks like toward like an shelter
something like that like if everybody
does that then in aggregate it makes the
world better place but it's like no one
person or no little group of people
especially not [__] scientologists
are going to improve the World by doing
whatever the [__] it is that they're
doing not by making everybody
Scientologist at [__] $40,000 $40,000
ahead yeah it's ridiculous the idea is
ridiculous every trailer park and
[__] get $40,000 out of them to get
them clear and then then we're going to
run them up the bridge which is you know
they got to go they're leveling up to be
a wizard
basically yeah because that's the thing
it's just like I kind of feel like
people that get into it they they talk a
good game about oh they think they're
going to help C clear the planet and
everything like that but I think deep
down they just want to be a wizard yeah
they want to be a wizard they want to be
a j essentially what it is and they and
they want to help you but you got to pay
them right you got to pay them 40 Grand
just to get
clear [__] fools Zach says legit if
they ever made a movie about scientology
I mean they kind of did which which was
the master master yeah which was sort of
loosely based on elron hubard it's
pretty close yeah I mean it's clearly
they changed all the names and stuff
probably so they wouldn't they wouldn't
get their asses sued but it's like
pretty close um but he says if they made
one who should play elron and who should
play uh
miscavage Tom Cruz should play miscavage
actually Tom Cruz could probably play
Miss gavage real well cuz he knows him
yeah he'd never do it ever no of course
not uh although that would be hilarious
yeah I would actually go and watch that
cuz I was like I want to see I want to
see this [__] show yeah the same size
too and uh they got the short man Mafia
going on short dudes took over [__]
Scientology short mean guys a short mean
guys yeah Tom's kind of mean evidently
yeah see see that not he's diabolical
see that is not shockman like and like I
said we've talked about this many times
before I know we always get talking
about like Tom Cruz and Steven Seagal
and all that stuff but it's just kind of
like I don't know why anybody would be
surprised that he was like kind of an
[__] I was like he always comes
across as an [__] to me
always always has done he's high strong
and he's
um comes across as
uh I don't want to say arrogant but yeah
guess kind of cocky he's cocky yeah and
I I don't I don't like that but he's
also kind of like some of his mannerisms
you can tell that they're kind of
affected he he's triying to influence
you and I don't like that either's
trying to trying to influence you and
trying to and he's not as slick about it
as he
probably and
uh and he's different for for each
audience he's tailoring everything to
he's a performer you know he's an actor
and he's using that as a [__]
Scientology secret power it probably
works on scientologists well it probably
works on Yeahs on fans too probably but
[__] like me I just be like man
knock that [__] off what are you doing
I'd have to meet him for you know other
people said probably end up said that
they met him and said that he was super
nice so I guess it depends I guess it
depends yeah well there's people like
that it's like some sometimes if you go
along with what the whatever their
little situation is then yeah they're
going to be super nice cuz you're
playing along if you don't play along
then they're probably like real [__]
antagonistic to I don't think it's a
person playing along with another actor
hm
maybe he was just that he wasn't like he
expected he was real nice did I heard a
lot about him I had to built up to what
he was
like although that was probably 10 years
ago yeah okay said I met him he's just
he's a nice guy you know that's that's
that's what that guy said
okay but they were working together so I
don't know right yeah that might just be
some [__] that they got to say cuz it's
not like you can come out later like you
made a movie with somebody and be like
man I hated that [__]
yeah you know you're not going to get
work again although I don't think he's
got a problem with that being ex
military myself and understanding the
cult understanding
Scientology he probably treats you
according to your station in his eyes in
other words what your rank is so it's
going to be hierarchical you know if
you're another actor and maybe he likes
your work he probably treat you as a
peer if you're a cult member that you
know you're lower ranking than him he
dab near he's dab near you're number two
in that [__]
cult um well probably at a social level
he probably is number
two top five he
easily so he's going to treat you kind
of like like in a military situation
like you know come here private you know
that kind of [__]
right yeah come here and wipe my ass
peasant clean this whole vehicle here
make sure that shit's vacuumed out and I
uh do do are they are they working over
there do they work they do work okay
show me that they work bring those
[__] out here cuz they cuss
like crazy in scient come here I do that
to you come here y you're supposed to be
skilled right you got hammers you got
[__] wood you got carpet and [__] I
want you tear this whole back seat out I
want you put me a whole bunch of
speakers the best speakers we got Bose
speakers in there he's you know he tell
him to do some [__] like that you know
what I mean rebuil put in a badass sound
system in a disco his [__] in a disco
ball in the back of his [__] Escalade
or something you know yeah it's you know
oh he would totally drive out and they'd
be yes sir yes sir yes sir Mr Cruz and
they'd [__] get in there and [__]
two days later that sh your ass some
more that [__] would just be decked out
he goes yeah you guys did pretty good
yeah no than all I gotta get the [__]
out of here it takes off I said I can't
I don't know I just can't Church
property I can't I can't get down with
that kind of situation that's like I
said that's why I would never join a
cult or anything like that I don't like
hierarchical [__] I don't like people
like lording [__] over me I don't like I
was like man [__] you you you [__] and
put your pants on the same everybody
else you not like the Infantry you're
not any better not like theant so don't
[__] tell me what to do you know what
I'm saying well I know that's why I
never [__] join because I don't like
that kind of [__] even like that at all
I don't like being told what to do I
just do not so that's so you know it
causes some problems but that's just
what I'm like I've always been like that
um Zach says I was never in a Tom Cruz
even before I knew anything about
scientology because something seems off
with his acting style it's very surface
yeah he always just comes across as just
very
glib and
arrogant and like there's not a lot
going on
behind this facade you know what I mean
I don't know that's just kind of what I
the impression that I
got um I don't know wait a
minute who is this Camp guy talking to
oh um Camp guy said I just saw a really
good in-depth documentary about that
Alec mura that was convicted of killing
his wife and son in South
Carolina oh yeah yeah yeah I did I start
watching that and then I didn't finish
it for some reason I think I that sounds
familiar maybe I did start watching it
it's like I never realized he was in on
a whole lot of other shade and Larsson
as lawyer stuff ripped off clients for
Millions also his son was driving a boat
when it crashed and killed a girl yeah
yeah yeah I did start watching that I
think I watched like the first episode
and I meant to go back and finish it I
don't think I ever did it's is it on
it's on Netflix right I thought it was
was that was a while back that I you
know what's funny is that um it's my
understanding that a lot of people who
are
like very wealthy Rich you know a lot of
most of them make that [__] off of fraud
embezzlement and [__] stealing [__]
from other rich people well yeah of
course really that's [__] where a lot
of it comes from and it's just kind of a
thing that rich people do steal from
each
other yeah I mean yeah
weird they're not they're not like the
rest of us that's for
sure K Jeffrey they don't know where
that money came from that probably giz
gay Maxwell's dad's money they never had
been able to figure out where they said
he was some kind of investor they he had
all these titles there's no proof he
ever made any money off of any of that
just a mystery man he's like a construct
like it had to be CIA had to be some
intelligence agency but they never
explained where he got his money nobody
ever did business with him in terms of
like you know uh he he's he would claim
to be doing currency training and
stuff but no there's no proof that he
had an
income
strange very mysterious yeah not really
I mean they're always doing all kind of
like [__] shady yeah he had all these
titles you know they call him all these
things but there's no proof that nobody
he didn't have any customers you know
yeah
um wait I just saw something oh yeah YP
post said Tom Cruz presents as a
psychopath that's kind of what I always
uh the impression that I always got as
well like he came across a very
um uh surface level like there like
there's nothing going on yeah u in his
mind or like behind his eyes you know
what I mean he he seems kind of blank um
Kayan says it's well he always seemed
like that to me it's why uh kayin Higgin
said it's why I can't help but feel a
little bad for people who get wrapped up
in Cults just for the sake of combating
their own loneliness yeah and that's the
thing and I think they definitely do I
mean why do you think like Cults and
larger religions too why why do you
think they target people like at their
most vulnerable you know what I mean
it's just kind of like oh you got
problems we can fix it we can solve it
we have like this big community and
that's very appealing for a lot of
people but like I said cranky
[__] like me I don't I don't uh
subscribe to that kind of [__] because
it's like I don't want to hang around
with people because I don't like people
so that is just not appealing to me at
all Jenny's a little harder on on cruise
than
me I don't quite see him the same way I
like a lot of his movies that yeah I'm
not saying I didn't I don't like some of
some of his movies yeah that last
mission impossible movie I thought was
really good um yeah it was I like pretty
much all those Mission Impossible movies
even though even the early ones that
were kind of hokey that first one was
pretty hokey I guess um well they were
movies of their time yeah yeah John Woo
was real hot director when that came out
just but
um my take on him is that he's a uh he
came from humble
beginnings he was a pretty he was a good
performer
um Scientology helped him they said it
helped him with dyslexia I don't know if
that's a code word for maybe not being
able to read I don't [__] know I
don't know where Tom exactly came from
in terms of what kind of guy I just
think he was a simple guy
he made a lot of money very quickly got
very famous real quickly and
um that probably very big effect on your
ego especially if you're kind of a a guy
from humble
beginnings yeah it goes to their head a
lot of times it it depends on the kind
of personality that you have though some
people turn out okay but yeah so then he
gets sheltered by Fame and the
cult and
uh I mean [__] I mean to be Tom Cruz's
girlfriend you got you that was like
applying for a job you know the cult
would make you jump through all these
hoops and make sure that you're good
good enough to even talk to Tom Cruz you
know some crazy [__] when you think
about it Nock is so he's not have he
didn't live a normal life no obviously
no
but um he's pretty skilled man can fly
he can good you can ride motorcycles
pretty well you know I've seen him ride
he can shoot he can fly aircraft you
know he he's not a dummy he's skilled
and a lot a lot of those stunts does
them so you got to give him that um and
when he's doing a Tom Cruz movie he
doesn't phone that [__] in man he's he's
giving it giving his all even that even
that [__] mummy movie that flopped I
liked that movie I did not I liked it I
thought it was
fun uh it didn't have anything to do
with the mummy nothing to do with the
mummy would someone please make a mummy
movie kind like the Boris caroff one I
mean we still have the Boris carof one I
mean I can just watch that because that
movie is awesome but it's just kind kind
of like if you're going to remake it
like make it like that yeah most of the
time he's kind of playing the same
character that the Tom Cruiser used to
seeing he's like almost like he's
playing himself I
guess if that's what you want to call it
well see that's how he yeah that's how
he always came that's I don't know that
because that's not him that that's
that's that same character now he he has
stepped out of the role like in
collateral I think he did a great job as
a psycho he makes a [__] great
villain uh I think his best role is uh
the Ethan Hut character I I think I like
he I thought he was great in [__]
interview the vampire I thought he made
a great lat cuz man lat's kind of a
villain you know likable villain and
that's a good he's good at that Tom can
pull that off he should do that more
often yeah but you don't want to be a
villain all the time his fans wanted to
see him as basically Ethan Hunt
basically or some kind of heroic dude
the that last Top
Gun the the remake of Star Wars really
what it was but it was essentially
basically destroying the Death Star yeah
I mean I think I we even said that in
the theater I'm like so it's he's
destroying a death that's what he's
doing okay it didn't go ined on I know
and I was just like right out of put the
star God damn it Porkins but you know
what I mean but yeah it was pretty much
exactly that it was still like a good
movie but I didn't get like I liked the
movie but I didn't get why everybody was
just [__] their pants over it was a
very traditional old school kind of
movie yeah and what I mean there's
nothing wrong
with that it's just it was I was just
saying I was just kind of like it didn't
really like I didn't really like the
first one either yeah yeah I didn't like
the first one I mean it's not really my
thing you know what I mean like I'm a
horror and indie girl I don't really
like those big Blockbusters usually but
Top Gun the first Blockbuster the first
Top Gun was not like a
blockbuster well not really it was it
was an oddball movie from from from from
the day that it came out it was just it
was a product of its
time kind of cheesy you know and but a
lot of movies at that time were yeah
yeah so it was karate kids I mean
everything was very but in a way I think
that's why a lot of people and even like
people well I think even people that
weren't even born back then and like you
know younger people now that are really
into ' 80s movies I think that's why I
think they like the um the earnestness
and it's definitely fantasy yeah it's
like I said it's very Earnest but it's
fantasy I think after the 90s came along
like everything had to be like snarky
and gritty real and ironic and [__] like
that like oh well we're too cool we have
to kind of like make fun of this we
can't like have genuine emotions or
anything but like the ' 80s ones were
just very Earnest and like very genuine
and so and yeah they were cheesy and
yeah they were over the top but they
weren't trying to be clever they weren't
trying to like make fun of the [__] or
anything like that you know what I mean
good 80s movie like you
said what what what I I would like to uh
I would describe them as they were
good-natured they were like a
good-hearted movie it was it wasn't
pissing you off it wasn't trying to
challenge you really it was It was kind
of junk food it was it was like it it
confirmed it confirmed your suspicions
that the world was a good place and that
if you did the right thing you could get
ahead everything would work out
everything would work out and that yeah
the good people were [__] rewarded
and the bad people were yeah is the
world really like that of course not
no but it it was that's that's great
positive propaganda because it it
[__] keeps people in a good mood and
makes them um uh I think it makes them
trust their fellow man a little bit
better because it puts them in a good
mood you put everybody in a bad mood
they'll turn on each other you know just
[__] in a military unit you'll see
that so there's certain elements of
positive propaganda are they're kind of
healthy uh for a societ society and that
was really
80s it was kind of like a way of they
were trying to [__] I think rebuild
Society after the [__] Viet war and
there was a lot of [__] up [__]
happening in the 80s well there was a
lot of [__] up [__] happening in
the'80s too and I think people were just
kind of like over hearing about it and
it's just like they just wanted to like
turn their brain off and have fun which
like you know sometimes people should be
able to do that yeah there was a massive
[__] crime epidemic [__] big wave
of crack epidemic hit there was big
crime wave was going on at that time
[__] um they started locking people
up for what the the three strikes are
out law you just three well I mean there
was a lot of [__] going on I mean it was
still kind of like um you know it was
still kind of the Cold War it was still
there was the AIDS epidemic there was
still like there was all of this [__]
going on and it's just kind of like so
people just wanted escapism I guess and
Hollywood made a [__] ton of money
selling that that was that was the good
call you could see dark movies they had
those too yeah and that's usually what I
ended up watching but I I liked a lot of
the um kind of f good escap good
Escapist Feelgood movies were [__]
great man like Beverly Hills Cop one and
two was like I loved that movie uh there
was just a lot of them from that time I
like the the Arnold Schwarzenegger
movies basically were like that Predator
not so much but Total Recall [__]
great movie kind of positive feeling
even Running Man
Commando they were just fun
movies were kind of like the platform
video games of the day yeah like that
too
they I think most platform video both
most platform video games were actually
kind of modeled after the Commando movie
because when you watch that movie it's a
lot like a video game of the
time scrolling by and different music
for each level there's kind of like
little boss fights it's just a lot like
a video game you know it's interesting
to me though and I'm not sure if this is
just me personally like just what I'm
like but it's like because I've always
been into gruesome [__] so I've always
liked horror movies and scary stories
and feel bad type of entertainment and
like sad music and everything but the
weird thing about it is that watching
[__] up horror movies or listening to
like really depressing sad music or
something like that actually like makes
me happy in like a twisted kind of way
and I'm not really sure I can articulate
why that is and so like a lot of times
if I see these real Feelgood movies they
kind of like piss me off you know what I
mean not always it depends on how it's
done but a lot of times if I go see a
movie it's like everything's awesome and
also I'm like shut the [__] up it is not
you know what I mean like I just I get
really mad about it said that [__]
plus he's talking about Tom Cruz he's
done a lot for the Lollipop Guild I know
hey man stop that [__] I'm in the
shortman mafia too man I think me and
getting offended yeah me and Tom me and
Tom are probably the same size you might
be well you might be a little bit taller
than Tom Cruz about five six I think I
always had the impression that Tom Cruz
was about my height maybe uh which is 5
foot three it depends no I think it
depends on what shoes he's wearing well
that the same can be said for me when I
have my big stacked boots on I'm taller
than you are I think he's around 55 but
in real life I'm about three inches
shorter than you I think he's about 55
yeah 55 maybe so he's not that much
taller than me maybe 5 he's a little bit
shorter than you then maybe with with
with some with some good shoes on he's
maybe
57 with some shoes with some lifts in
there evid he's got them [__] I got them
but I don't [__] hide them I got big
goth platforms that's what I mean put my
[__] demonia on and [__] damn no
I'm [__] 5 foot 10 well like I said
see that's kind of the thing that I
always liked about kind of the goth
scene and stuff like that it's like yeah
we we wear all this like artificial [__]
but we're not like hiding it looks like
a [__] Frankenstein on the B we're
not trying to like pretend that we
really look like that yeah it's all AR
defense yeah when I
got version of it too so actually the
height difference maintains the same Jen
becomes tall as [__] too in that [__]
yeah cuz I've got a few boots that are
like really really tall don't be don't
be don't be surprised when them goth
girls take their shoes off and they
[__] their
KN damn one you're like a foot shorter
than you were when I saw you at the club
earlier yeah my friend Damian's
girlfriend man when whenever whenever I
see her out she'll stand up [__] give
me a hug [__] because when we show up
to the club and she'll have her flat
shoes on not her Club shoes on and I'm
constantly reminded how little yeah she
is cuz she seems so tall she seems tall
because usually when we see her we're
out and she's got these big stacked like
platform boot
but when you see her with flat shes or
without shoes on then she's like really
short she's maybe
410 yeah she's about 410 probably little
bitty thing May about 85 well and our
friend Sonia was like that too it's like
she would wear these big platform boots
out but then like you forget she was
like not even 5 feet tall no not even 5
feet tall not even five 41 yeah she's a
lot shorter than me and I'm pretty short
she and she weighed 80 lbs probably if
that if that and and five of those
pounds worth
implants
yeah yeah Zach says um I know what you
mean Jenny I also hate Feelgood stuff
because most of it feels phony yeah feel
bad stuff just feels more Earnest to me
I don't know why yeah and it depends I
don't I don't necessarily just want to
see something that's just like wallowing
in misery but that can be fake too but
well yeah that can be fake too so that
can also be overdone like look at this
horrible [__] and I'm just like all
right just stop it but um I don't mixure
yeah I do as well it's it's just I seems
I don't know it it depends on the on the
movie or on the medium I tend to like
feel bad type of stuff I tend to like
stuff with like unhappy endings I tend
to like stuff like that but it depends
it depends on the story I like any kind
of story that seems like it's organic or
seems like it's that's the way it's
supposed to be I think my perfect
mixture from that era would have been
Beverly Hills Cop one and
two it was a feel-good movie
they had happy endings in them but
people got killed in them there there
was a sense that yeah maybe you know
what I mean maybe the characters are in
danger but you know you're just [__]
it's a suspension of disbelief right you
know but U you don't want a thing where
it's just kind of where it's like
everybody like all the cool characters
have plot armor which is what they call
it like you know that they're not going
to get killed cuz Axel got shot yeah in
a couple of them and the last one and
and three I think he gets shot up pretty
bad but they live I think he gets shot
the second one two
but it's like in the arm or the leg you
know I mean that kind of
[__] I love in those 80s movies like
somebody gets shot in the arm or leg and
it's just kind of like they're they're
they're like oh ow but they're still
doing [__] go right back to yeah
fighting a dude you would actually not
be be doing that I'm sorry you'd be like
um I need to go to the hospital please
if it hit bone that arm it would just be
[__] D it would just be you're you're
not going to be fighting with anybody
you're not going to be driving a car
you're not going to be climbing up the
side of a building you're not going to
be doing any of
that yeah [__] uh Indiana Jones got
shot in the arm fought with the [__]
German truck
driver it was adrenaline man and he got
punched in the arm three times in the
bullet wound right and he still made it
to the damn ship and got out of there
and [__] what is it just a few scenes
later it's like it never happened yeah
they always kind of they do that a lot
and like well they still do it now but
they did it that back then
too because like I said they don't want
the person to get killed but they want
it to seem like dangerous but they're
like yeah but we want them to still be
like badass and keep fighting we can't
just have them laying there laying in
the street screaming which is what they
would really be doing but I don't know
we me and Tom talk about this all the
time because he's always just like well
that wouldn't really happen I'm like
yeah but it's a movie sometimes you
can't put like what's realistic in a
movie because no one want to [__]
watch it it has to be like there has to
be some fantasy element it just can't be
so much of a fantasy element that it
takes you out of the story I think is
what the is what the dividing line is
because I don't really mind
if um you know if it's trying to be like
a quasi realistic movie and then there's
like stuff in there that it's just like
oh that wouldn't happen that way or blah
blah blah but it's just kind of like I
don't know as long as it's a good story
and as long as it kind of makes sense
and it doesn't pull me out of it then
it's
fine um John gor said bone Tomahawk kind
of needed a happy ending after all the
horror yeah and it's like if you do that
um then I don't really mind it if you
haven't seen bone Tomahawk please
[__] see it it's so good I mean I
feel like a lot of horror fans know
about it
nowadays but um that had bone Tomahawk
had and I've watched a lot of horror
movies okay and it's like Gore doesn't
bother me nothing like that that had one
of the most [__] up one of the most
[__] up deaths in any movie ever it
was just and I think it was more
shocking because the movie for the first
2third of it I want to say was not
really a straight up movie it's like a
western and then it just goes fullon
horror toward the end and then you see
this one scene and you're like what the
[__] am I watching holy [__] great
[__] movie though it's a great
[__] mov bone Tomahawk oh yeah great
movie yeah that's a great got Blu-ray
I'm just amazed though you know Jenny
will walk in and I'll be um watching
reaction
videos and I like to watch younger
people react to old classics like a war
ones and uh you know just old Star Wars
[__] like
that there one I've been watching
recently I think it's called villagers
react it's these two guys from I think
it's
Pakistan they don't they don't speak any
English but they're reading the
subtitles and
uh they're showing them all the classics
man and they're they're [__] tripping
out they're they're like uh late 20s
probably and everything that [__] we
loved as kids they [__] love
it the thing scared the [__] out of them
they [__] loved that nice they love
and then afterwards he goes the guy with
the beard man he looked good with the
beard he had a beard you they talk about
[__] about Russell they liked him
yeah and then they were like man you
couldn't trust anybody love for Kurt
Russell I feel like is pretty Universal
another one they liked is they love
[__] Predator F the first Predator
alien one and two they [__] they lost
their [__] on that um they saw uh the
Terminator uh what else a couple of the
Arnold Schwarz movies they call caught I
think Terminator 2 they saw
that and uh Predator this so they just
by watching these movies they don't even
know who these peoples are that you know
they don't know these actors they've
never heard of the movies when they and
they don't have the same cultural
context have different generation and
everything well these two dudes just in
like four movies became huge Arnold
Schwarzenegger when they saw um what was
uh RoboCop they Lov RoboCop one
everybody loves Robocop and the other
guy Missour goes this is a great movie
but I got one problem he goes the
RoboCop guy that should have been Arnold
Schwarzenegger that was his only
complaint yeah yeah yeah yeah that
should have been Arnold Schwarzenegger
don't pick on Peter that that worked
that worked they thought that should
have been arold Mar they loved [__]
RoboCop that blew their [__] minds
and then the guy who sh on the movie
says there's a part two and oh we got to
see
that oh we got to see that yeah so they
just have no
context but they know a good movie when
they see it that's cool well like I said
good storytelling is universal yeah yeah
they could not they saw a new hope you
know the first Star Wars they couldn't
believe that was 1977 they they like all
space movies yeah they saw alien first
that [__] scared the [__] out but
they liked it they're like man that
movie is Scary they they got it and
everything everything they understood
everything about it in terms of the
tension they said that the [__] music
was [__] with their heads because
that's got a spooky soundtrack it does
yeah and then uh sound design and score
are a big part especially of horror and
I think it doesn't get the credit that
it deserves when they told them that
today we got aliens this part two alien
one you saw last month they were like
oh they were already scared sced when
the movie starts you know right yeah and
then when they found out when they
realized with all those eggs have been
exposed they were already because oh
this must be must be a million of them
yeah yeah yeah they got it they reacted
the same way we did and the comment was
is they say I can't believe that they
were making this in the 80s yeah yeah I
mean they were [__] well made s said
the same thing we showed s when s was
over we showed s alien one and two and
she had not seen
she couldn't believe that aliens aliens
was all practical effects she's like
that was [__] amazing CGI when that
was no CG when did aliens come out 86
right was that 86 yeah about that around
that time I thought it was 86 I think it
was 86 yeah cuz alien was 79 yeah but I
don't think aliens came out till
1986 and although I feel like well I you
know I'm not going to get mad about it
but I do kind of feel like aliens is one
of those movies that everybody brings up
as being better than the like you know
one of the few movies where the sequel
is better than the original it's
different it's just different honestly I
prefer the first one because it's more a
straight horror movie whereas the second
one is more like action horror yeah but
I mean they're both [__] great
obviously I never met a single person in
my entire life that didn't love the
Alien movies that and that didn't love
the thing and Predator I'm sure they're
out there but I've never met them yeah
now I have met some people that didn't
like the shining which I don't
understand because that's one of my
favorite movies ever um but I have met a
couple people that that hated that but
those other ones I don't think I ever
met anybody it's just it that would be
like saying you hated like Back to the
Future who the [__] hates Back to the
Future nobody everybody loves Back to
the Future it's just one of those movies
yeah another ones that they showed U the
Pakistani
guys they showed them um Rocky they
[__] loved that they were going
through that whole thing you know they
he better marry that girl all that kind
of [__] and they he he you know that he
want that he fought the fight to to uh
to a tie that blew their mind they
hadn't seen part two of that but then
they showed him Rambo that [__] them
up too they liked Rambo the book is good
you might like the book actually I read
the book a long time I read a book that
was kind of like that was called this
the park is
mine oh I know yeah I know what you're
talking about I think that's where that
story came from um it well I don't know
about that because like I said Rambo was
based on a book um that was actually was
actually based on a book okay I have
heard of the park is mine though I
thought that that's but I don't know if
that's if it came out before that or if
it was just kind of like a I don't
remember when the book that was that um
that Rambo was based on came out okay I
wanted to say it was 70s but I can't
remember exactly what the park is mine
is pretty old I read it a long time ago
it's also 70s I thought that Rambo was
based on Parker's mind you you guys
don't know what I'm talking about yeah
Ben said Rambo is from First Blood by
David Morell yeah that's right yeah I
read that like a long time ago but is
that a was that a copy of the park is
mine oh I don't know see I don't
remember I've heard of that book I don't
think I've read it but Park of M the
park this park is mine is real close to
a Rambo type situation it's a Vietnam
veteran I forgot why he got pissed off
he he got pissed off at crime I think in
Central Park in New York yeah and he
goes in there using his uh Vietnam
skills and takes over the
park he's got [__] bunkers and
tunnels diging dug all through it he had
assault rifles and all kinds of [__] I
don't think he killed anybody though
it's just that he played like this cat
and mouse game if I remember correctly
he just played a cat Mouse game with
like the fire department and the police
department I think they brought in the
National Guard and he [__] them up
they didn't kill anybody that's way and
then I think they capture him in the end
or he gets killed I think in the end but
that's how I remember the book I read
that book when I was like 16 so don't
quote me on all that it was a long time
ago yeah I'd have to look that up yeah
John gor said they were actually going
to get Arnold for RoboCop I heard really
but his asking price was probably high
and they needed a skinny guy to be in
the suit um and then Ben said yeah the
actress's physique wasn't that important
for RoboCop it was basically just his
face and then YPO said uh Weller was way
more sympathetic than Arie had the
capacity for yeah I'm gonna agree with
you on that I don't think and we've
talked about this before too it's like
Arnold Schwarz uger movies are great but
it's like he's a character like if you
want somebody that's going to play like
a person um you know what I mean and I
don't mean that like in a weird like
he's not a person I'm just saying if you
want somebody that's comes across more
sympathetic or comes across more like a
real person then you don't want to get
Arnold Schwarzenegger because he's like
Larger than Life you know what I mean
he's like a Persona you know what though
except for his first big movie Conan the
Barbarian he had a lot of good scenes in
that that were cut out of the of the uh
of of of the theatrical release and
they're cut out of even the U the
Blu-ray
release and really I think Conan is one
of his best works and and that that
movie [__] John
milus I mean it's it's it's a [__]
mythological Masterpiece you
know talking about
[__] what's his name uh
nian philosophy man it's a [__] great
movie the second one is no not so good
no not could have been
good well could have been I remember one
time I was talking
[__] about kodan 2 my disappointment
with it and it was one of the guys that
one of the bartender not bartenders one
of the bouncers at uh independent bar
remember yeah and he goes yeah but you
know what that is a faithful adaptation
of the Marvel comic books and I thought
about it and went yeah it is yeah yeah I
guess yeah so I think it they went for
like a comic book tone it's just I well
because the first one wasn't like that
so I it's a jarring change of tone right
I think that's the problem that I had
with it but he said plus it seemed like
they cheaped out they did well they
wanted a they wanted a PG rating because
they thought they wanted to get the kids
don't ever [__] and then the new
director said well I don't want to go
the millius rout route let's go the
comic book
route and it would have worked if they'
had good boss fights but the costumes
for the [__] monster bosses [__]
sucked it didn't work it looked terrible
you could fix that movie I watched it
recently maybe about four or five years
ago and I thought you know you could fix
this movie with if you would replaced
the original boss fights with a CGI
scene it it' work is that was the
problem the fight scene sucked yeah when
he killed that wizard remember that that
wizard had the Lizard Head
yeah and there was stuff like that in
the Marvel comic
books Wizards that had lizard heads and
[__] like that but it looks a lot better
in comic book when it's animated when
you're drawing it or yeah when you're
when it's just a dude in a like cheap
ass costume suit you're like what the
[__] is that you know so just take his
mask off yeah don't give him any
Halloween candy yeah you
know it's I I don't know
anytime that you make an R-rated movie
and then the sequel they're like oh we
want to bring in the kids on this so
we're going to make it PG-13 it's always
it's I mean 99% of the time there was
another one that came out after
that called red Sonia yeah I've been
wanting to do I've been wanting to do a
movie review on that cuz I I remember
seeing that on cable like a bunch in the
80s I remember liking it i yeah I think
my brother probably liked it more than I
did for obvious reasons and Arnold's in
it but they couldn't and it was supposed
to be kodad but they didn't didn't they
didn't have the license to call him they
had to change his name and I want
toen Duke something or other count
something or other you know Prince I
think it was a prince I think is what
they called but
U the thing is I went to go buy that
Blu-ray and they [__] wanted a [__]
ton of money for it is it super rare or
something it's rare Ben says I have red
Sonia on 4K yeah said I used to have the
VHS and I pretty much it out yeah I want
to see it again man like I said it was
on I feel like it was on HBO Cinemax
like all the time like in the 80s and
the early 90s we want to review it if
yall want to review [__] send us the
Blu-ray and we'll review or I can never
get around to it or I can look on
streaming and see if it's like because
we have a lot of streaming services that
we pay for so we maybe there's on there
maybe there's one on there yeah so it
could be would mind owning it though I
think for a while it was on I want to
say it was on tub which is why I thought
about reviewing it because I saw it when
I was scrolling through thought there
was another one I thought there was too
thought for some reason I'm thinking
there's another one that I'm always
forgetting about or maybe it's maybe I'm
confusing because there was like a bunch
of like sword and sorcery movies another
one that had Arnold Schwarzenegger in it
oh I don't
know that was a Conan
spin-off if I remember correctly [__]
and it wasn't a Conan movie and it
wasn't red Sonia I thought I think there
was another one that he was
in maybe I'm thinking of something else
see I thought that too but now I can't
remember he
red now I can't remember uh Ben brings
up pumping Iron the documentary great
movie which is yeah which is actually
I've seen it a couple of times it
actually like is a lot of uh fun movie
to watch if you're if you're into that
dude and then Ben said Arnold was never
trained as an actor whatever yeah well
that's kind of obvious he used his
natural Charisma and intelligence to
adapt to the roles yeah I mean and in
certain kind of roles he kicked like he
was awesome in The Terminator he was
awesome in like anytime he didn't have
to like emote or do
anything I don't know like it's like and
he got um better as he got older because
and we brought this up a lot of times
but if you are new here or something
like that um just a couple years ago
what am I I think it was 2016 2017 when
did that movie come out Maggie uh 2016
but he was in a zombie movie with um
Abigail I think it was Abigail Breslin
it's a great movie and it's a zombie
movie and it's called Maggie and he
played the dad he was the dad and his
daughter was zombifying right yeah and
he her from and he was trying to hide
her from the authorities like so she
didn't get taken away because they were
taking away like all the zombies and
stuff and he was like actually great I'm
like wow dude can [__] act like when
he wants
to well I'm G to have to disagree with
some of this [__] okay look uh oh Arnold
could act he just had a strong accent in
some of the delet deleted scenes of of
Conan uh if you can go on
YouTube go look for Conan deleted scenes
what there's a scene that they call
introspection and he talks
about the uh the spring wind and him and
subai are talking about and what they're
talking about they're talking about the
effects of PTSD and they're wondering
man 20 years of pess combat and other
men are getting married and this and
that don't you smell the spring wind and
all that kind of [__] now it's a
youthemism for shouldn't we get married
and you know become family men and super
TI like yeah but it would only just
leave me back here you know and [__]
and then I'd be fighting next to a dude
who was nowhere near as [__] badass
as you are and like yeah maybe you know
what I mean and then [__] Conan says
yeah for us the spring wind is just
fcking a dream you know and what they're
talk this is happening after Vietnam and
you know millius was big military buff
man he wanted to join French he wanted
to join the uh the US Army for first and
then the Air Force but he he couldn't
pass the
physicals he wanted to join the French
forign he said if this movie was going
to bomb he was going to join the French
Foreign Legion so he did that he
directed that movie with a legionnaire
as [__] Beret
on so he was always talking to soldiers
and [__] guys coming back from the waren
interview and and they started to like
notice that the dudes that were coming
back from Vietnam when they were in the
field they would constantly think about
going back home and and women and girls
and [__] like but then as soon as they
got home all they did was constantly
think about getting back to Vietnam and
that's kind of what it's like to to have
PTSD you you don't you you you get
addicted to it um you don't feel right
at home because you're not fulfilling a
role it's boring you want to get back
into where a more stressful environment
because you've adapted to that and
that's where your identity was formed
you know so you're trying to get back in
into some kind of danger that's what
superai is talking about in there so
that's why that that's why that scene is
in that film but they took it out for
time well during that scene Arnold
[__] does a great it does the best
acting out of that whole
movie the thing that held Arnold back
was his accent especially in those days
yeah if you had an accent in the 70s in
an American movie it it the the the
audiences [__] didn't accept it for
some reason because they they Associated
foreign film with something cheap
because they had been seeing all these
damn either cheap or like Arty farty
yeah or Arty FY so they didn't mostly
cheap because they'd seen all these damn
Chinese and Japanese kind of cheap
movies dubbed into English and they
looked ridiculous but if you saw them in
their original language they didn't look
anywhere near as bad it's just that when
you that's why I hate dubbing yeah
dubbing [__] is terrible other than
gialo movies I give gialo movies a pass
for dubbing they dubbed that's how they
come
yeah they all they they just do that
well because and not just because oh
American Market it was because the
actors that were in it were from
everywhere yeah so they would usually
just everybody just speak their own
language and we'll dub it all into other
languages later on just don't worry
about it so so Arnold could act it's
just he had a strong accent yeah and
that was one of the reasons why they cut
that out for time and his accent was
really exposed but they [__] milus
talked the the the dino rent to Studios
and it said no man we got to have Arnold
Schwarzenegger this dude from Pumping
Iron we're going to have him in it
you're like yeah his English skills no
no no no no we're doing Conan he doesn't
speak English Conan doesn't speak
English this is [__] happening in
another yeah I mean you can get away
with a lot more when it's like a fantasy
it's a fantasy say it worked well but it
was so popular man people kept calling
him back to do more movies nobody ever
thought that Arnold Schwarzenegger would
conquer Hollywood and become governor of
California but that's that's exactly
what
happened I mean most other people that
would not have been able to no and it
was on the back it was on the back Conan
and then later on [__] um uh I think
what was the one after that I think it
was I think it was
U Commando I think that came after that
or the Terminator come after that no it
was Terminator came out for I thought
Commando and then I thought Commando
didn't come out till 84 or
85 if I'm not mistaken
well they all what's funny about Arnold
is he filmed them kind of each year he
filmed like two or so they were all
coming out around the same
time there' be like three Arnold spartz
Saker movies in a year if I remember
correctly so he was just like Bam Bam
Bam there was a lot of them yeah and he
didn't know which one were going to be
popular you know but
um he was good though man I his movies
were great I liked them they were for
the time they were just you just
couldn't beat them they they they gave
the audience audience what they wanted
and the audience was basically a young
male audience you know that's what they
wanted to see yeah so yeah it was spot
on and really I from I like Terminator
was [__] kicking ass everybody
talking about Terminator 2 you know I
like that that was okay my favorite one
was actually Total
Recall and and it was a lower budget one
but I liked it I liked the
story you know was he tripping yeah he
was tripping he's on the he bought the
ego trip n that happened was in his head
he he was back at
recall yeah we have a whole discussion
about this he was tripping yeah he never
none of that happened in Total Recall I
mean the clues are all there yeah the
clues are all there although my little
swo [__] numb and it did Happ no it
didn't happen every single time
seriously our friend our friend Matt who
Tom calls L wall yeah um every time
these two are out together yeah they
inevitably get into a discussion about
Total Recall yeah because Matt believes
that he actually did go to Mars and all
of that stuff happened yeah and Tom
keeps trying
to about this and that what about the
bullet what about every single time so
it's like I'm over there talking to
somebody else and I can hear them like
talking I'm like are they talking about
total recalling they're arguing about
Total Recall because he wants to hold on
to the
dream and that's what that's what the
ego trip was all about right when he
asked him he says so if I buy this trip
the memory
in yes you actually believe you know
went wrong that's how it was supposed to
go and they told him [__] he picked
secret agent that he wanted to be a
secret agent he even picked what the
girl would look like that he could beat
yeah and that's what she yeah he picked
everything ahead of and then there
there's showing the damn Martian ruins
from the alien Martian ruins they show
it scroll by when they're loading it in
thing and he you will absolutely believe
yeah they wanted to be as realistic as
possible so they [__] layered the
fantasy right in with this reality right
that it went wrong no no I actually was
a secret agent I was a that's why I
selected all that [__] right because I
knew deep down I was a secret agent you
know yeah so that was that's what's so
awesome about that movie man that's you
know that's the that's the kind of [__]
Philip K dicks would come up with I
don't think I don't think the the
original story is exactly like that but
it was in the spirit of that yeah yeah
and the spirit of
dicks it's just it's it's just one day
I'm okay dick dick is dick dicks it's
just one dick Zack is it dick or dick
it's a single dick it's just one single
dick that's [__]
funny yeah Ben says you can argue the
ending of Total Recall both ways yeah
and I I do kind of feel like well that's
what's so great about that movie is that
you know you can uh you could read it
either way it's more likely I think it's
more likely that yeah he got what he
paid for yeah that was what he paid for
I don't think anything went wrong I
don't think anything like that but I
mean yeah you could argue that but it's
like I don't think that I don't think
that no I think I think that's what made
that's see Not only was it going to
convince him it was going to convince
you the viewer that that [__] really
happened it didn't though that was part
of the ego trip he took a vacation from
himself and became a secret agent on
Mars sure great movie great movie and
it's mostly great because of the
writing you know the special effects the
sets were kind of cheesy looking but you
know for the time it was good yeah when
I mean what year did that even come out
I forgot maybe 87 I thought it was 87
yeah yeah yeah YP PO said identity
ambiguity is Dick's thing yeah yeah um
Zach says all the dicks that can fit in
an orifice I won't name and you know it
Tom damn damn we got to get this on
video we are kind of we GNA get this on
video what all the dicks going in in an
orifice
we're gonna have Z star and Direct in
that [__] and we will distribute yeah
okay we're going to have we're going to
have a whole Distribution Company at
this point yeah I mean you know I might
need another drink I feel like yeah yeah
yeah I'm getting empty
yes yeah John Gore said Michael Ironside
was great in it too I love Michael
Ironside I just I kind of feel like he
doesn't get the
um the I don't know I I was going to say
I guess he doesn't get the recognition
he deserves but maybe he does I love all
those character actors man I never
really liked all the kind of like
A-list uh you know actors and actresses
they all because they all seem kind of
like interchangeable so I was like I'm
always like interested in like character
actors you
know um Camp guys bring up monsters ball
that was a great [__] movie I've only
seen it once or twice though like I
think I saw it in the theater when it
came out and I might have seen it one
more time after that but that's another
one I definitely need to watch and I
think somebody brought up like Sling
Blade earlier too which is also a
fantastic movie I don't think we ever
did we ever review Sling
Blade does anybody remember I thought we
did but um now that I'm thinking about
it maybe we didn't and maybe we should
because that's another [__] great
movie is [__] Sling
Blade Zach said I first learned who
Michael Ironside was because he voiced
Sam Fisher in the Splinter s games yeah
I mean
he's the dude has been in
like tons of [__] I mean he's been in
tons of
[__] thank
you and then what was what were what
what were you talking about before about
Peter
Bole uh D oh they're talking about the
deer hunter I think that's another one
we never did review I just watched it a
couple of years ago
but
um yeah when was Total Recall 86 I
thought it was
87 but now that I'm thinking about it it
might have been a little bit later it
might have been
1990 now that I'm thinking about it
although I might be wrong but I like
thought it was
1990 and then yeah con and the Destroyer
yeah we were just talking about that
earlier I don't think we ever did Taxi
Driver either we did do running man I
know we did
that which
is which if you you know uh maybe maybe
maybe most people know but that's a
Stephen King adaptation but it's a lot
um different than the story not super
different
but that it's a fun movie though I think
the the story is a lot more dystopian
which story The Running Man a running
man yeah whereas the movie is kind of a
lot more fun or like funny yeah I liked
the running man I didn't to I remembered
a lot about it you know what I mean it
stuck with me over the years these are
of course you know movies from our child
childhood you know I don't call him
childhood but my I was going to say my
teen it was my teenag teen years you're
like [__] oh man you cuz I was I was
a teenager in the 80s like I graduated
in 1990 I still kind of think of it as
my childhood but yeah it was [__]
teen yeah yeah but the uh great thing
about it is it was the timing was right
on it the tone was right on all those
Arnold Schwarzenegger movies very few of
them were misses Raw Deal was a Miss I
own it yeah I didn't love it and raw
deal was a miss I didn't but most of
them were real good the tone was [__]
great they were
taken as a young man they're taking
young men a young men on these [__]
mental Journeys down these [__] crazy
[__]
situations and Arnold you know Jen
saying he can't act like just way he
can't he could act he was acting exactly
like we expected him to act he became a
thing you know I mean and you expected
him to be like that just pay him for
he's not an actor in the sense of he's a
performer yeah he's perform two
different things because somebody that's
an actor I expect that person to
disappear into the character I want to
forget that that's an actor that's kind
of what their job is you're you're
playing a role I want to see that role I
don't want to see the actor which is why
if you get too famous that can really
hamper you in that regard because it's
like everybody's just oh it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger oh it's Tom Cruz they're
just being that Persona and they're not
Vanishing into to the role like an actor
would that's what I mean but it's two
different things it depends on like what
it's kind of like Tom Cruz people
weren't really paying to see him vanish
they're paying to see that same
[__] again do that same thing
over and over yeah he was like a an icon
or not was he was an avatar yeah it' be
a good way to put it or something I
don't know icon icon bit word he he you
expect you wanted to see that same
character again over and over and over
again in these different situations want
more of that and you know he's kind of
playing himself uh or you know partly or
at least what you see of as himself CU
you know listen to a lot of interviews
what he was really like he's a he's a
goofball in real life he's not real he's
not wasn't a real serious guy [__]
around a lot and um Jen has said it
before you I kind of said it he his
onscreen Persona was kind of not sexy he
was not I wouldn't call him like a hot
guy even though he's [__] as good-
looking as he was he's said he just
looking at [__] was Mr Universe
you know and I don't I think he did
Olympia too or maybe did he do Mr
Universe I I think it was just Olympia
but
um his chemistry was not a sexual
chemistry on on film no it not but women
that knew him said he was [__]
addictive that you got to taste of that
you weren't going anywhere he said you
couldn't stay away from him so you know
that's not ref as a man judge evidently
he was kind of like he didn't want his
roles to to be romantic or be like that
at all they were just kind of like
symbolic mythical yeah kind of
characters you know which you said he's
more like an avatar than Anar person
yeah um he had only a couple misses
collateral damage sucked I think a lot
of it had to do with timing and it was
about terrorism and it just was well
some of his later movies I didn't like
like end days and end of the days was
mediocre had great special effects but
the the story really didn't pull me in
the the last of a [__] good Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie that was like in
the Arnold
Schwarzenegger brand that tone like
Total Recall
and Terminator and what would have been
sixth day the sixth day I like that one
yeah that one was all right and I think
a lot of people have forgotten it that
was the Clone one right yeah yeah and it
had [__] uh yeah you showed me that
yeah and that was like going back in
time that was like the last real Arnold
swarzenegger movie like a classic movie
but it was what was that maybe uh
2006 maybe yeah I was going to say it's
fairly recent but it was like well no
it's not that recent it was it was like
had Michael Rooker in it and we always
love Michael Rooker yeah he was in it I
like Michael Rooker and everything and
it had that strange
sci-fi tone but it was slightly upbeat
but Sinister at the same time I liked
that I thought it was a great movie I
own
it
um but uh that era passed you really
can't make those kind of movies
anymore well I mean you can but you
people wouldn't really care not quite
the same yeah it's not it's not really
they were better in the past well and
well and I think the reason that is
because they were better in the past so
it's like there's not really much point
in making them anymore because just kind
of like it would just be like ripping
off like the old ones cuz they've
already made them so it's like why make
it again yeah I listen to some of these
other channels and there you're
bemoaning how much modern movies how a
lot of these modern Hollywood movies
suck they do suck but the thing is
though man there's so many good movies
in the past that you can watch and you
can own them I mean that's the thing
that's why I never piss and moan about
it because one not all modern movies
suck it's like there's lots of good ones
there's millions of movies out seriously
like it's not necessar big Blockbuster
but it's like you know if you look
around there's good [__] everywhere um
but you know there's not just that so
it's just kind of like there's and not
just movies but books and like all kind
of [__] but then there's like a lot of
stuff in the past like I said you know
going back like a [__] Century
there's all kind of [__] you can go back
to so I'll never run out of good [__] to
watch or read so I'm never going to like
I'm not going to piss and moan about
even some of the newer [__] has some of
that old fashed charm and it was great
one was a French movie had Michael
Ironside in it called turbo kid loved it
and that was kind of like a I thought it
was Australian but thought was I thought
it was French Australian or or kiwi or
New Zealand maybe I thought I can't
remember reason I thought it was French
it's on Tubi I think yeah it's it was
last time I L it's all in English but I
want to see I've only seen it once I
[__] loved it I really like turbo kid
it was kind of like an 80s movie the
same guy that was in Turbo kid like the
main one of the main actors was also in
this great horror movie which I think
was Australian called bloody hell um
which you might like actually I loved it
I thought it was fantastic it was on
shudder I don't know if it's still on
there anymore but it's fairly recent I
think it came out in 2017 2018 and it's
fantastic it's like a I guess it's like
a black comedy but it's really really
gruesome and I really dug it if you
haven't seen turbo kid check it out
turbo kid's really good too it it's uh
action comedy
um imagine it's a post-apocalyptic movie
done in an 80s style kind of like Cherry
2000 or something yeah it's got it
reminded me very strongly of cherry te
postapocalyptic or a man in his dog or
or that kind of Yeah Boy And His Dog
sorry it and it's post-apocalyptic but
it's a post-apocalyptic superhero movie
yeah yeah I think we did a review of it
actually maybe we did great movie I own
it I think yeah I think you do it might
be on tub I'm pretty sure be for free no
I don't own it I don't own it John
Robertson says Jenny I recommend a novel
psycho sanitarium by Chad Williamson it
follows the time when Norman Bates is in
the Asylum I'm watching Psycho 3 now and
I'm like please leave the mentally ill
man alone please I love all the psycho
movies um I think we did uh kind of like
a big review because we have the um the
four movie Psycho set I also have the
Bates Motel series which I'm still I'm
still on uh season 2 unfortunately I'm
trying to to like get through it but um
we did like a big review of all four of
the psycho movies and I will go to bat
for all the psycho sequels honestly I
think psycho 2 is one of the most
underrated horror sequels ever made it's
a great movie all of the psycho sequels
are good but psycho 2 is fantastic I
love that [__] movie and I I will
definitely go to bat for that
one because you know
honestly like I think other than because
we've talked about this before but as
far as like horror franchises go where
like all the movies were good I thought
all the psycho movies were good and all
of the fantasm movies are good whereas
like some of the other bigger horror
franchises obviously like nightmare Elm
Street or Halloween or whatever it's
like some of those were like hit or miss
but all of the fantasm movies were all
five of them were they're all good
that's great that's and all four of the
psycho movies were good yeah yeah um
hold on
yeah Ben Ben said that that uh turbo kid
was shot in Australia yeah I thought it
was because like I said I was pretty
sure this I was think it was French or
the director was French or something
maybe no it's Australian yeah see I
thought it was crazy for a second Nicole
said she just did a big order on Sheen
because of us yeah yeah that you'll like
it we get a lot of [__] there we're
going we might make an order this week
maybe we'll see because I want some
stuff from there I mean we'll see I'm
kind now I'm kind of scared because it's
like now that I'm back um working
without a net again yeah don't worry
about it we'll make it but but like I
said once I crunched the numbers and I
was just like well technically we only
have to
work we have to get 48 paid minutes a
day yeah to make as much money as I
would make it we get 48 paid minutes
within about eight hours yeah I mean you
can be on as long as you need to like to
get that many the rate that we do it we
usually at at the rate hourly rate that
we go by we can get that done usually in
about six hours upon averages so it
should be a problem yeah I think and and
we can go on and off as necessary like
we can go on for an hour or two and if
it's slow we can just be like ah [__] it
we'll come back on later on or whatever
yeah man when you're dealing with Sheen
you want to spend at least a hundred
bucks to you can get the uh free
shipping and they got a good tracking
you they'll track they'll even send you
an email when it's going to be delivered
that day and I saw who delivered it it
was just a dude in a car with his
girlfriend takes about a week but about
a week yeah I think usually when we have
ordered from there it usually takes
about a week I was like who's delivering
this [__] and just saw a dude in his car
filled with packages with his girlfriend
next to him and they came up here it is
so they they're hiring local delivery
people but uh the I got a whole Wardrobe
from there yeah for like literally
couple hundred bucks yeah maybe $300 300
bucks yeah and that's and that's
including like not just dresses pants
Tops and stuff like that but that's [__]
like wigs
necklaces Nails [__] like that like
accessories shoes sex toys yeah although
some of the sex toys I got off of that's
for the show um but no this is actually
Sheen right here man yeah this is so
well this quity this necklace is too
yeah yeah that's NE the quality is good
this wig is not I had this before and
the boots the the quality of the goth
boots on there is about the same as
demonia so it's a good deal yeah I got a
really nice pair of like um Mary Jane
type shoes that are like super shiny and
they have have like a um ankle strap and
yeah they're cool looking yeah she said
she spent about $120 says it's going to
be her on the 9th which is about a week
yeah that's about right yeah and I think
she's only worn about onethird of the
stuff that she's bought I haven't had
time to wear all this stuff yeah but and
some of it was just like a couple of
bucks yeah I go I had to buy like one of
those rolling wardrobe thingies like you
see like backstage at plays and [__]
like that and it's just kind and I had
to buy like a bunch more hangers because
I didn't have enough so I have like a
whole [__] I have a whole [__]
wardrobe in there and like I said
there's like several outfits in there
that I still haven't worn yet and all
those cool goth stockings are all
good yeah I still got a bunch of
packages of those that I hav with the
gers that all built in and everything
and the one one piece [__] bodysuits
for women and [__] you know basically
porn outfits yeah
they're only like two bucks yeah we got
like all the work outfits yeah yeah it's
all it's work they're not all well
they're not all black either we got some
like I got a hot pink one and I got like
umow one that's like rainbow yeah
Green we get a we get a green one I
don't think we
got I remember the graen the the rainbow
one and the hot pink one and we got a
couple black ones too a couple pair of
shoes yeah goth
shoes I really like those shoes that I
got there they're about like they're a
little bit lighter I think the platforms
on them aren't they a little lighter
than or is that the same
weight probably about the same that's
say I mean they seem like decent quality
yeah yeah Manny Nicole said yeah I'm
revamping my wardrobe yeah I was too
yeah just think made like three if you
make like three orders of a 100 you'll
have a [__] ton of
clothes I'm going at it next I haven't
bought much from there there's not the
mint selection isn't quite as good but
uh there's some [__] I want to buy on
there
I still haven't tried it one of my
favorite things that we bought recently
that I haven't really got to wear yet
was it's like a
floorlength
red dress but it's like see-through you
know what I mean yeah like you could
like you know you wear like a braon
underwear underneath it no I haven't
worn yeah yeah what's funny about that
it's cool looking it's got a pattern on
it that looks like it's sticking to your
body it's even got [__] like booty
cheeks and it's got some but it's not
super obvious real obvious but it's
shaded right they basically they've
shaded and highlighted the thing to make
a
woman make her look more voluptuous and
more more like it looks really good I
really when I tried it on I really liked
it a lot yeah but I haven't had I
haven't worn it out yet I don't know I
mean now now I might have the balls to
wear that out but wear some booty shorts
underneath it I might have the balls to
wear that
wear it wear it to uh wear it to the
club I could wear well we're going to um
momentum Mor on Sunday night maybe I
could wear I'll see how it looks yeah
see how it looks I mean I might not even
need a corset under that no I wouldn't
think the whole thing with that is that
the the less you have on the better
that's the idea behind that cuz last
time I went to bar another month and
you'll you'll
F although like I said I tried it on
like several weeks ago and it looked
good then so I was like and I've lost
some weight since then so yeah it'll
probably but um last time we went to
momento I didn't even wear a corset I
wore that dress with the um and I think
we did the show beforehand so so we
probably saw it but it was where the
it's cut out on the side yeah yeah it
looked good yeah and I had a lot of
compliments about that yeah I had a lot
of even like the um didn't Lorraine who
was the owner's wife said to you it's
like whatever it is she's doing tell her
to keep doing it
yeah whatever she's doing keep do
it so you
know but we'll see maybe I'll wear that
maybe I'll wear that red thing we'll see
how it we'll see how it looks cuz I have
been wanting to wear that somewhere CU I
do like it a lot it's sexy yeah it's
cool looking I like it yeah and I think
it it's cheap like how much was it eight
bucks it was $8 yeah $8 yeah you guys
have probably seeing these ads man it's
like we're [__] advertising ping but
you proba seen all these advertisements
on YouTube for [__] teu yeah cuz
their ads are everywhere teu it's like
teu but but the prices are even lower uh
because they don't have any advertising
just Word of Mouth advertising and they
use local delivery they just hired some
subcontractor is going to deliver your
packages but you can still track it and
they sign it up it's been reliable takes
about a week it's not like Amazon it's a
lot cheaper and the quality and the
women's quality and selection's
excellent yeah I've been very I've been
very happy with most of the I mean I
because I was expecting it was going to
be like wish you know what I mean where
it's like like you know half the time
the [__] would be okay and then half the
time the [__] would be like made of
paper didn't look like the picture or
anything like that totally normal good
quality but everything I've got from
there has actually been like really good
quality just stand up show show them
that and I have a dress this was from
the fairy cor collection yeah I had so I
have this one which has what does this
have on it roses or flowers or something
sh skulls and yeah skulls and [__] like
that but see that's like that and I have
another one like this that's green
that's like an olive green what show
them the shoulders the shoulders have
they're like poofy like they're like
poofy shoulders get put it in the camera
put a shoulder in the camera oh what
like that yeah yeah and it's that's what
the shoulders look like and here's the
thing St up what what's cool about these
is that show this to the camera what
this it's actually adjustable yeah yeah
yeah there's a tie right here as you
tighten it up it goes up as you want you
can have whatever whatever length you
want or you can make it long so it's
adjustable yeah you can 10 bucks it'll
go down to your knees or if you want to
make it like short like a mini skirt you
can like you can tie the sides and so I
have one like this and I have one that's
like um kind of like an olive green that
has like moths on it yeah now now back
in the day let's say you went to back in
the '90s or something and because that's
like a almost a 90s style yeah you went
to say like Hot Topic at the mall they
charge you 40 bucks for that back in the
90s you can get it through she had for
about 10 1011 it might have been 14
maximum yeah I don't think some [__]
some of these shirts are like $3 you
like man it's got to be like [__] you
get it and it's like a [__] awesome
little little chick's shirt you know
what I mean little maybe it's a half
shirt belly shirt type thing with a star
on it stuff just C it's cute stuff yeah
they have a bunch of different
collections
I love shopping for women's clothes but
I can't wear them of
course you're a little too big yeah it
would look good good but the men's stuff
the only thing that's good there is kind
of like sports wear muscle shirts
[__] gym shirts [__] like that the
rest of it is all kind of like kind of
very like Asian preppy or Asian [__]
looking
um video game player or what do you call
them like something out of a video game
character like like uh yeah which you
know hooded jackets with slits and it
just nah you know it's
not if I was 20 maybe but at my age you
just really can't get away with that
kind of [__] would look stupid anyway
skinny jeans and [__] like that
yeah October said what is the tattoo on
your arm on this arm this is kind of
like a um like an owl goddess kind of
situation this was actually our friend
Jacob um I just let him go Hog Wild on
the [__] and let him draw it so he just
put that on there and then this arm is
um Anubis yeah so
yeah [__] anime man M's going I'm so
excited yeah yeah it's always cool like
when we get like a ship from there yeah
it's going to come in a big plastic bag
maybe and it and it sometimes the
shipment comes in two or three pieces
cuz if it's not in stock they got to
hold it back but they'll send you the
rest of the shipment first most of the
time we get most the time it's in one
but sometimes it's two yeah but that's
good because they're trying to get you
what they have as quickly as they
possibly can Ben said did it hurt um not
really and this one in
particular um like I said we uh our
friend Jacob did this one cuz he was a
tattoo artist and this took 10 hours
normally a tattoo this size they would
do it they wouldn't do it in one sitting
they would usually do the outline at the
first sitting and then you would go back
and get the shading done um
but I didn't really want to go like do
it in two go so I was just like n [__]
it just do the whole thing so he
actually sat there and did the whole
thing and it took 10 hours
and um it didn't hurt I have a pretty
high pain tolerance
so it was just kind
of irritating but after a while like
after 20 30 minutes you don't really
feel it anymore because you just kind of
get used to it you
know not like I mean I say I have a high
pain tolerance but then there was that
whole nipple piercing
situation but that's kind of different
because that's not like getting attached
too especially one that's takes 10 hours
you know it's after a while it's just
kind of like it's not sharp pain it's
just kind of like irritating pain it's
like a sunburn it kind of feels like a
like like a sunburn so after a while you
just kind of get used to it because it's
just kind of like the same thing like
over and over and you're like oh that's
what it's like so you're just like used
to it but the piercing was different
because that was just kind of like one
concentrated
pain so that hurt a lot but tattoos have
never bothered me it doesn't really it
doesn't
hurt but yeah I was just I don't know I
was just he this is probably not super
um legal but he came to our house he was
a friend of ours and he came to our
house and did the tattoo this was years
and years ago and he did the outline and
I don't remember how long the outline
took um but he was like well he's like
normally you know you do the outline and
then you let that heal up a little bit
and then you do the the shading and the
color and everything and he's like but I
could do it now it's like if you don't
want to you know if you don't want to
wait or you don't want me to have to
come out here again or something like
that and I was just like you know what
[__] it let's just let's just do it so I
sat there for 10 hours and he sat there
for 10 hours and did the whole thing
so yeah Mandy said yeah it's irritating
skin pain not too bad uh my tummy hurt
and my chest and neck but most others
are okay yeah it's
most like once you get in there and it
cuz it's mostly just a
constant like just annoying pain like a
buzzing scratching yeah like a buzzing
scratching or like I said it kind of
feels like a bad sunburn you know what I
mean after it's done after it's it kind
of feels like that so but once you get
used to it it's not because I was saying
I was saying that it's like nothing like
the the nipple piercing that was a whole
different yeah that was a whole
different thing but um that that was
traumatic for you as well
yeah man [__] I thought Pearson and
nipple would be like sticking a eagle
through me to giving your an injection
cuz we do that all the time but yeah no
it's like sticking a damn sharp iron bar
through a bunch of
[__] crunching
[Laughter]
[__] I don't know I still can't
believe we [__] did that I still
can't believe it cracked and popped
stretched I was like oh [__] man like I
was thinking about it like a few days
after I'm like did we just [__] do
that we just [__] did that we're
crazy went through one and then you only
had like a 10minute break and did the
other one she almost didn't want to do
it the second one say no we're going to
get this out of the way she's crying
already oh my God she like this is going
to suck I know and uh I really didn't
want to do since all that I've been
noticing [__] some of these [__]
porn chicks they only have one bar and I
was like we know have there exactly what
happened I kind of feel I understand
though I understand I don't I don't play
with them and that was the first
piercing I done I don't blame them I
showed them to uh my buddy Bill who who
did it for a living he goes God that's
good for a first attempt he that's right
cuz it's good job they're they're
they're straight and they're deep enough
set in back so they're not hanging off
the front you know what I mean they're
so they kind of push in a little bit
they're sexy they're cool I I really
like how they came out I really do but
it's just kind of
like wow that was really yeah very
painful yeah about the kid to do it and
studied it but seeing somebody else do
it on videos [__] know that's it's
not the same it's like no obviously
because you got to
put you're got to stick a needle through
there first and then you take the bar
and put it back the needle push the
needle out with the bar so one replaces
the
other and it's just [__] the first
time I did it the needle I put through
was too small so I couldn't get the bar
to go in after
follow so I wasn't thinking I should
have just taken the bigger needle and
pushed the smaller needle out instead I
pulled the [__] little needle out and
had to redo it did you should have just
[__] used the bigger needle and
pushed the small needle out which would
have been you wouldn't have even felt
that it was already through but you see
you were so uncomfortable I was [__]
kind of like head was kind of like I was
afraid because wasn't thinking clearly I
had started to black out yeah and I was
like well that's not good yeah I didn't
expect that women can handle a lot of
pain more than a man really women can
handle a lot of pain Mandy just said
working uh working in a shop for years
girls always uh say through them both
most men only got one though yeah it I
believe it and honestly most tattoo
artists I've known have said the same
thing that girls handled it better well
women in general tend to have a higher
pain tolerance than men in general yeah
not every I mean everybody's different
like individuals but selected that way
through natural selection having to go
through child birth and everything yeah
which is like the [__] worst well H
sets off too many [__] warning signs
in a man's [__] mind he wants to
start becoming violent so that's part of
the reason why they put dudes under
anesthesia hold dudes down or punch them
to knock them out back and before
anesthesia no they'll jump up try to
fight get the [__] off
me yeah even though even if it's saving
his life you know it's usually it's
utation it was the old school way it
never seen that yeah [__] Battlefield
amputation it send you to the damn
Barber
the barber was the surgeon yeah that's
how they did it back then yeah yeah I'll
cut your hair and uh put some leeches on
you cut [__] off cut your leg
off hope you don't get gang green
yeah but you know usually they H A Dude
down and a dude [__] wrap something
around his neck give him some whis boom
and [__] knock him out and then they
cut the leg off and hopefully they got
the [__] leg off before he woke up or
came to imagine that
yeah yeah using a bone saw on a dude
that's basically half a wig what are you
doing down
[Laughter]
there ghetto anesthesia yeah that's what
it was I mean and they had to make a
slit fing pull the skin back so when
they made the cut there'd be extra skin
that they could pull over and fold and
then well yeah you you can't cut right
there well yeah you can't just leave it
like that inches up in there you can't
leave it like that right you can't just
like leave an open wound that large no
well you can't just cut a bone and then
have no meat that's what I'm saying to
cover it so you have to have more meat
than bones so you got to get cut it in a
couple inches it's harder than it seems
yeah not that I've done it for just
saying they said what made a good
surgeon was how fast he could work
that's all it was well yeah getting it
over with really quick can you imagine
like before they even had [__]
cuz man the anesthesia they have
nowadays like when I had my [__]
surgery I don't I don't remember a
goddamn thing yeah we were real lucky it
worked really good yeah I'm just laying
there on the table with my little
blanket and my little footy socks on and
there's like okay count backwards and I
was like
19 you know what I mean and then like
however long it was like I woke up and I
was like it feels like something's
sitting on my chest then I fell asleep
again and then 6 hour hours later I was
[Laughter]
fine but yeah I mean yeah gen like I
said individuals you know individuals
are different but in my
experience um women do tend to tolerate
pain L better yeah I've always tolerated
pain better I think other than before I
got the nipple piercing I think the um
the worst pain I ever
experienced which is weird and random
but when I was
younger I was a pre-teen or a young
teen and I used to have
constant ear infections I felt like I
always had [__] ear it feel like my
ears were always bleeding or
something so I went to a doctor and they
had to take a sample of whatever it was
that was going on in my ears and the
doctor put this
long metal
thing in my ear and it see seemed like
it went all the way to the middle of my
[__] brain I know it didn't but
that's what it felt like like it felt
like he stuck it just all the way in
there
and that I can't even describe what that
felt like it was just like the weirdest
and my mom was with me and she said you
didn't scream or yell or say anything or
anything but she said the color just
fell out of your face she's like I saw
it happen
so until I got the nipple piercing I
think that was the worst pain I'd ever
experienced like that thing like stuck
in my ear that felt like it went all the
way into my brain but other than that I
haven't like luckily I've never broken
any bones I sprained an ankle real bad
one time like I slipped off the steps at
my um grandmother's house I thought I
broke it because it made a horrible
noise like it went pop and I was just
kind of like oh [__] well I broke that
but it didn't hurt at the time um I was
just kind of like oh I think I just
broke that cuz it made a horrible sense
sound and when I went to the doctor they
did put a cast on it but they said well
it's just a really bad spring and it's
you know you're lucky in a break it cuz
I have big [__] horse bones but um
honestly I had that cast on for like an
hour and the place I lived at the time
had stairs and I got so sick of sliding
up and down the stairs on my butt that
after a week I cut I cut the cast off
myself because I was like [__] this [__]
it's fine I'll just put an Ace bandage
on it you know what I mean that's that's
kind of I'm like I'll just deal with it
myself I'm not worried about it that is
Mandy oh wow all right yeah I just I
just subscribed to you Mandy oh okay
yeah yeah October said I was born with
bad ear at hole in my eard drum it
sucked but now I don't care yeah I
always had ear problems growing up now
it's just like I'm kind of half deaf but
again I'm kind of used to it it blows
but what are you going to do
yeah Mandy says hey hey yeah
yeah it's from a several years ago but
oh okay you're looking going to be
looking the same two three years ago
Zach said worst pain I ever had was when
I had a dry socket after I had my wisdom
teeth out they put me on oxy at the time
and I could have got addicted to it but
the pain was so bad it just evened out
honestly you know what and I've heard
that like with people's um teeth and
stuff but I um for whatever reason
reason um I guess like when my wisdom
teeth grew
in um I guess my mouth was B enough to
accommodate them because I never had to
have them like removed or anything I did
have a tooth in the back that's that
broke and like came out but it didn't
hurt because it happened like over
a kind of a period of time but I've
heard that people that had like really
you know like a bunch of [__] done to
their teeth that it was like really
painful but I never had anything like
that you know what I mean yeah what's
the worst pain you've ever experienced
Tom I don't know whenever I got
seriously hurt I didn't feel it broke my
arm and didn't feel it just my arm was
hanging I think that happens a lot of if
the injury is is um you know significant
enough I think your brain is just like
nope just to you know and that's kind of
a mercy actually yeah my grandmother
told me the same thing that
you know she's passed away now but she
was mowing the lawn one time and she ran
over something that popped out and like
cut a
huge like thing out of her leg you know
what I mean and it and she said she
didn't even feel it she's like the only
reason that she knew something was wrong
cuz she just kept on mowing the lawn and
then she's like why am I why is my shoe
like what am I am I stepping in mud and
then she looked down at her she was full
of blood ran over her own foot huh well
no it she ran over something that
that came back and like sliced her Lego
yeah when I had that motorcycle accident
put me in a coma and didn't feel
anything woke up it was several years
several weeks
later um when I came off the bike couple
years back maybe about 65 or 70 remember
when I hit that cat yeah didn't feel it
until I until later until later um oh
you felt it later yeah I remember that
if I ever get into if I ever get into a
fight I never even feel a single blow if
I get hit in the head don't even feel it
it's just a white Flash and a dud some
more like I hear it and you feel it you
just can't feel
anything
um trying to think what else um it's
weird because like I said and Zach
pointed just pointed this out said if
you ever had that thing happen where you
get a cut and don't realize it until you
see it and only then does it start
hurting I had the same thing happen like
when I was in junior high my dad took me
to school on the back of his motorcycle
my mom was so mad like I guess he didn't
ask permission before he did this I was
like 14 or something and I had never
ridden on the back of a motorcycle
before it was terrifying but we got to
the junior high it was fine and I got
off the motorcycle and my dad didn't
tell me that you had to get off on a
certain side to prevent yourself from
getting burned on the tailpipe well what
happened was that my leg pressed against
the tailpipe and burned a huge
thing like on my calf but I didn't um
feel it at the time that it
happened so like I get off and I go to
class and then like later on I happen to
look down at my leg and there was a
massive like oval blister it was like
sticking out like that far and I was
just like what the [__] and then like it
I didn't feel it at first like I didn't
feel it when it happen
I didn't feel it later on but I just
like looked down and saw and I was like
what the [__] happened there and then I
thought back and I was like oh [__] I
must have got off on the wrong side of
the motorcycle and like burn my leg on
the tailpipe but and it got bad it was
like I think it was a second degree burn
of course I didn't go to the hospital
for that either because I never did but
yeah so I just like put ointment and
[__] on it and it's I had a scar for a
long time I think it's gone now but I
had a scar for years and years like this
big oval
scar like on the side of my leg but I
didn't feel that when it happened either
and that was like a second degree burn
if you're not looking at it I guess
which maybe that's your body's way
of keeping you from getting too
traumatized maybe maybe the reason that
I felt the nipple piercing was because I
knew what was happening you know what I
mean it's not like it was sudden we were
prepared for it
so and even then I mean it was I was
expecting it to hurt it hurt worse than
I was
expecting
but H
yeah come
here this cat getting fatter P don't
don't call her fat maybe she's lost a
few oun what's up Pokey look everybody
wants to see
you she's like yeah I'm done with this
[__] he like I just want attention yeah
especially now that we have the other
Kitty yeah little little Bambi as we
call her Dakota is the name that she
came with but we started calling her
Bambi but um or Bam Bam or little bam
I'm G to slow that light down back
behind oh right I got you going too fast
that's cuz we lost power today yeah
because the power went out because of
the
storm but and I don't think it's cycling
through all the collar it might
not yes they're talking about oh
everybody's talking about their worst
pain now uh Mandy said my worst pain was
stepping on a nail ooha went through the
top of it and I passed out yeah I don't
blame you I was 12 and had a birthday
party someone's buff military dad
carried me across the street back home
my my little brother stepped on a
soldering iron I remember that he
screamed his [__] head off oh my God
he was like little he was like a toddler
Ben said I got a [__] awful burn on
my forearm when I fell asleep in a chair
with a blo heater blowing on me holy
crap and then Tammy said gave birth to
two kids no meds my tattoos were nothing
compared to that yeah I bet that's one
thing that I'm kind of glad I never
experienced we were talking about that
the other day I was just kind of
like I was pretty sure you know and I'm
old now I'm almost I'm you know I'll be
51 this month actually it's September
now so I'll be 51 at the end of this
month but it's just like I even when I
was um 15 16 years old I was pretty
aware that I was like I don't think I
want to ever have kids and I you know
and it's just like everything else like
your family oh you'll change your mind
when you older blah blah blah but I
never did I never did
but um I'm just I don't know I'm just
not cut out for that I guess and I knew
that at a pretty young age I was just
kind of like I'm pretty sure that's not
for me and like I said I and I was
familiar with the [__] because you know
my parents had because I had three
younger siblings that had a [__] ton of
cousins and my parents ran a daycare
center for a long time like they ran a
daycare center like away and then like
my mom ran one in the house too like for
a time so I was always around kids and
you know even when I was a kid and I was
just kind of like look I'm a kid too but
it's like I don't like being around
other kids and I can't deal with this I
know it's different when it's yours
everybody says that but it's just kind
of like I didn't want to me and Tom were
talking about this last week I said I I
didn't want to get as because the thing
about having kids is that you can't
really take it back so it's like if
you're ambivalent about it you're like
oh well I don't know well maybe it'll
all work out when I have them but it's
like but yeah but if it doesn't and you
have a kid and then later on you're like
I this isn't really for me I don't
really like it there's nothing you can
do about it you're just kind of stuck so
it's was just kind of like I would
rather air on the side of caution you
know what I'm saying and I'm glad I kind
of did put some more ice in this yeah
the ice melts like so fast we have the
fan on and [__] the ice isn't cold
enough I
guess yeah Zach says I think the second
worst I had was when I had food
poisoning so bad it was coming out both
ends and my belly was messed up for a
few weeks after food poisoning is the
[__] worst I got um salmonella once
from I think I was at Wet n Wild which
is like a water park it's not there
anymore but it was in Orlando and we
used to go all the time with my parents'
daycare like we would go a couple times
a summer and I got some chicken strips
there for lunch and I ate them and then
when I was halfway through eating them I
realized that they were
undercooked so yeah I got Sal vanilla
from that and that really say salmonella
is no fun thank you oh you're like
handing J me that's
yeah uh John gor said broken ribs suck
yeah I've never had any broken B every
time you breathe I've never yeah that's
what he said makes breathing rough I
have actually never broken a bone in my
whole entire life isn't that crazy no
it's not crazy a lot of people have gone
through without breaking a bone nobody I
nobody I everybody I knew had broken at
least one boat usually their arm like
while they were playing like falling off
some playground [__] or whatever when
you're a kid yeah yeah that's what I
mean but uh you know if you live a
civilized life a lot of people could get
through it I broke a bone and didn't
know it I broke my broke my little py
toe one time and didn't know it I I
might have done that without knowing it
but yeah they they x-rayed my foot and
it says when did you break your toe and
I said what know anything about it break
my toe it's a little toe yeah it doesn't
do anything I kind of vaguely remember
that I had a pain there a long time you
know what I mean like ow don't touch
that you know what I mean but it's a
small bone yeah that's what I mean it's
just it's a [__] toe mhm oh I did
CRA I didn't break it really but I did
have like a hairline crack in my
tailbone okay from like falling on a
well it was like I I'd been sitting on a
stool and I kind of like slipped and
like fell and it kind of like cracked my
tailbone so I did have to like have the
dut pillow for a while that's when I was
in high school I think and that hurt a
lot but you
know um let me see October re said I'll
see you to later after to go to work
okay well you know have a good time does
anybody have any questions or anything
anything you guys want us to talk about
maybe other shows other cases
movies Zach said there was also a couple
times I almost suffocated choking on
Candy as a little kid and the asthma
attack I had that made my left lung
collapse oh boy I never choked but my
brother almost did we had to do um well
I didn't but one of my parents had to do
the heck on him I don't remember what it
was that he was eating that he was
choking on
though I was always kind of paranoid
about that cuz what if you were eating
by yourself and like you [__] didn't
they used to show well when they showed
you the him lick you always had to um
they showed you how to do it on yourself
like over the back of a chair and [__]
so Mandy says I wonder how many hot dogs
have killed people probably a lot you
know what it might have been a hot dog
now that I think about
it cuz man that's like it's all tubular
and like slick and it'll go right down
your [__] throat it's all Tu and
Slick oh [__] man our gay is
and right and then we segue right into
like the porn portion of the show like
we're like we usually
do it's just well for whatever reason
that just made me think of um all of
those eating
contests and why does it seem like so
many of them are hot
dogs you can get a lot because they're
meat you can get lots of it for cheap
and you have TOS well the thing about it
is that like the eating contest that
they have for for the hot dogs like you
have to eat the bun too but they usually
like soak the bun in water which is
gross as [__] I mean I love Hot Dogs I'm
not saying that but it's just kind of
like I don't know to me it just seems
like takes all the fun out of eating
like just cramming all that down your
gullet and it's always skinny
people it's always skinny people that
win that blows my
mind Zach says oh no what a way to go
death by deep throating a
shaft right there's that's a whole
that's a whole porn sub
genre um Alex Rivera oh okay this is g
to be this is going to be a question for
you Tom you'll enjoy this okay I have a
question do you think there's any way
for a person to control rspk or is it
just random oh and also as an adject to
that you messaged me two days ago
Thursday yeah something happened again
um that something happened it was minor
but was kind of like that time that so
talk about that it was kind of like the
time I was uh looking for the motorcycle
key couldn't find my motorcycle key for
days this was a couple years ago couple
years back and I was sitting in front of
the television on the end of the bed and
Pooky was rolling around thatting crazy
my feet and I'm like that she likes rest
I looked down and I saw her reach up and
grab something and I was like and then
she was biting it was what the [__] is
that it was the motorcycle kid
you tell me and we had torn the [__]
house apart yeah for days looking for
that thing motorcycle key had a like a
rubber end on it's a bule
key little blue and she was sitting
there on it and I was like she likes you
on rubber I was just like where the and
I saw her catch something out of the air
wasn't looking directly at her you know
was little B to the side I saw her reach
up and catch something that was like was
falling okay well like the like the
polter guys dropped it on her she was
like oh toy thank you yeah she didn't
notice she didn't notice anything
strange well a couple days ago Pooky
that's why I mention this poy was in
front of
me rolling around and fighting [__]
hair bands she loves hair bands you can
buy her any toy in the world she won't
[__] with it but if it's one of Jenny's
hairbands she will [__] she goes in my
bathroom and steals them I had to buy a
whole other thing because all my other
ones are gone because she's like she
picks him out with one toe and she's
like she puts in her mouth and she looks
around like oh [__] I'm but and then she
like runs and it away and hides it some
place pook's odd Pookie is the only cat
that I've ever seen that'll pick
something up with one paw and throw it
and then Chase it yeah so in this
[__] whirling I'm watching television
and okay the television is on a big like
a like a stand a television stand and
it's got a little drawer and then
there's a slot for the Xbox and I got
some battery charging equipment [__] in
there it's
black and uh I had the shade cracked and
there was it was the dark the room's
dark I got damn Galaxy [__] being
projected up on the screen and [__]
colored lights in there you know the
whole house looks like a [__] the
whole house looks like a Pakistani
brothel or some [__] like that color
lights we got nightclub lighting
nightclub lighting to the whole thing so
um Pookie playing and I'm [__] with
her I'm looking at television and I see
her stand up and throw the
[__] hair hair band or the uh what do
you call it hair band right yeah yeah
it's like it's like a like a rubber band
like the black rubber band it's your
throw it one paw and see it go through
the
air and basically land next to the Xbox
in that slot and she ran over it and she
stood up on her back legs and I could
see her [__] her hands looking for it
looking for it where'd it go that went
on for a long time maybe 10 seconds or
so and she's still looking for it moving
up and side side to side side so I said
okay so I grabbed the flashlight cuz it
was dark there I saw it go into the
darkness in between the two little
levels grab the flashlight I always got
a flashlight next to me there [__]
military you know where's my flashlight
it's dark in here too so if I need light
I [__] yeah we kind of like it darken
yeah I got a uh [__] solar power
rechargeable metal [__]
metal flashlight can break [__] glass
and on the back of it it'll make a
[__] electric Arc you can make
[__] Spark and [__] start fires with
it so went go over there and turn the
flashlight on and look for it I couldn't
find it I like where is that [__]
thing Pooky looking for it too knew what
I was looking for picking up the Xbox
and moving [__] around there's not much
there this is and I looked behind the
thing I pulled the
[__] the television stand out a
little bit looked for it wasn't there
and I turned around to go sit back down
and that [__] was next to the
nightstand on the other side of the room
on the other side of the room yeah
that's one of the very few of the weird
things that's
happened oh mean going back to [__]
what it happened at Mammoth it was real
[__] wild very active for about two
weeks three weeks two weeks probably let
me run and go to the bathroom nowadays
it's just kind of intermittent I'll be
right back sometimes it might not do it
for years sometimes it might damn you
looking good I'm gu
that yeah let me get some that the uh
all right the question was
is kind of person control
it theoretically yeah I wasn't able to
though as soon as I tried to do it it
went
away that was when when I was a kid
so I suspected that I had something to
do it I thought it was a read in my mind
because if I thought of an object that'
be the next object that moved and I'd be
like man that [__] that that
ghost was reading my mind it knew that I
was thinking about that object object
and moved it and I told my Uncle red I
says I think this thing's reading my
mind he what do you mean I said I was
just thinking about that object and it
moved it and he was a little bit wigged
out he was like yeah [__] it can do all
this other stuff it can move these
objects maybe it can read your mind
that's that worried
me then I don't know guess it must have
been about six seven hours later I said
maybe it's not reading my mind maybe I
think of these objects and it and
somehow I move it
so I said what I'm going to do is I'm
going to tell these objects to move so
I'd be like I'm going to get that object
to move over
there and that stopped the whole
phenomenon that's when it
stopped trying to do
it so then it would be you know I didn't
see it again for years later but then it
would manifest itself in different
ways well did you say that you kind of
have a theory that actually trying to
control it like supresses it yeah it has
something to do with the way the human
mind is set up it's the unconscious mind
that's doing it not the conscious mind
so when you're because most of you is in
the unconscious and there's more than
one facet to your personality you're
kind of like a a complex of multiple
personality complex going on in there
they're all checking one one another and
they're discussing things amongst each
other before you even think of it so
there's kind of like this there's kind
of like this Perpetual conversation
going on back
there because I [__] kind of lived a
weird life it's kind of hard at certain
times um The more stress I'm under
sometimes that it evens out to
nothing um sometimes the internal
conversation can get pretty loud in
there if I'm bored it can get real loud
if I'm bored and under
stress it's like
different things in there talking and uh
some of them are bad that's why I'm kind
of scared of this uh poist I'm scared of
it too yeah I mean I know it's you never
heard anything it's never Hur anything
but there's you know but you never know
yeah there's a first time for everything
yeah like I said and I've told you that
before especially like at our old house
when all of that [__] was happening and
even though in a way I don't find it
scary scary because I know it's you it's
not like it's a demon or not like I
believe in demons but I'm just saying so
it's like so I know that it's you but
then knowing that it's you and because
I've known you for such a long time I'm
like well it could be that that might um
might be bad and badly yeah like you
might get you might be like get a
certain kind of way one day yeah and um
some bad [__] might happen yeah you know
like some like a you might get like cuz
I told you before like you might get
like mad at me and like like a brick a
fly in my head or something from some
place he never thrown anything heavy at
anybody I mean that's the thing it's
only thrown things at me actually yeah
and I mean look look I've known you
forever you've never hurt me you've
never come close to doing anything like
that so it's just kind of like I don't
think that it would happen but it's just
like I don't know it was it's just kind
of like that what if okay most dangerous
thing it threw was a knife a kitchen
knife and threw it it threw it at you uh
well no it went across of me and that
was before even mat you that I was a
little kid when that well a little kid I
was about 14 13 14 13 you were and it
did that in front of everybody yeah they
were just gasp you know and it sailed
out of the kitchen in a straight line
not an arc straight line point forward
went right in front of me and it went
right to Lois's sliding glass doors
didn't hit the door stopped maybe a half
inch before it bounced off and hit the
ground with a thud boom and didn't even
bounce right at my feet
and all my hair stood up but all [__] it
was being thrown and stuff was
moving minutes before this so I was kind
of warmed up to it and I immediately
went into into denial I was like that
didn't happen and Red's like come over
here man come go over here and I said
did that happen he goes yeah that
happened and I immediately kind of shake
that off cuz that was kind of it was a
not it was a weapon you know that scared
me um yeah Mandy just said mine tends to
be triggered when I'm under extreme
stress and my hormones are out of whack
I had a spoon when I was around 14 15
hit me on the leg on top from coming
from on top of the coffee pot yeah yeah
a similar kind of thing is what you had
yeah um now can you control
it I would say no not consciously the
only thing that I've been able to to
do at
will is things like astral projection
but you have to do
it basically by there's a certain
feeling you a certain Vibe you got to
get in it has to be kind of like
Transcendental
Meditation and you have to kind of like
ramp yourself up for
it and
um once you're re relaxed you have to
basically Surrender Your Soul it's kind
of like going through a willful death to
allow yourself to die but you don't die
it just feels like you're dying then
you're you're out but the thing is is
that you're not
sometimes you're out you're looking down
at yourself but a lot of times you go
into
like uh some people have called it like
the astral world but I don't think
that's an accurate point to sometimes
you'll appear in someone else's
dream you know that they're dreaming and
they see you in their in their dream
sometimes they remember it sometimes
they don't you can't really choose where
you appear sometimes it's weird I told
you we need to start try to start doing
that yeah the thing is is
like it's been a long time since I've
done that
yeah there's weird [__] that you see
over there and uh the first time it
happened spontaneously was like two or
three days before that motorcycle
accident where I had that near-death
experience it was almost kind of like
like a precursor like a precursor
because I think with that part of your I
think that part of your mind
is outside the normal SpaceTime
Continuum so there's no difference
between now and the future or the past
so I mean it was really a near-death
experience was in a coma for a
while well and so I think it was
actually kind of part of a death process
but it I didn't die though and you told
me too that people saw it happen well
and you told me too that just prior to
your motorcycle accident in which you
were in a coma like after that um you
went out of your body before the
accident or at least so it seems seemed
like at the time at the time yeah was
riding the bike I was like you saw
yourself from above like before you were
I didn't never go through the I didn't
never go through the accident I left
before the accident happened yeah that's
how my memory went some people say well
you can't trust your memory when you had
those head injuries well that's true
yeah but that's just the way the memory
was and I kind of believed it because a
lot of stuff that had happened did a
whole show on it it's um I there we did
a show about adab experience and we've
done a couple shows about the Mammoth
Mountain thing that you went through
riding the bike at that time it was a
Ninja ZX6 that I
had zx600 actually it was [__] tuned
to the gills too that [__] was
hot this is uh 1993
1994 I just remember going down the road
going to turn turn some videos that I
had rented back in was out in front of
Fort camell Kentucky going to the video
store this when I was in the Army I only
had a few months to go before my uh etss
before I got
out so was going down the road and I
looked over to my left and saw a shadow
of myself and the Motorcycle being cast
on the ground and it was like real
mesmerizing and I was like man I sure
lived a good life you know that kind it
was that kind of thing you know what I
mean spooky and I was like you know and
then I realized I wasn't seeing my
shadow actually I was looking down on
myself riding the
bike and it did kind of look like a
shadow and I I felt like there was a big
bright light behind me and I looked over
and I was say look at me riding a
motorcycle I was like where that where's
that light coming from and I just
remember turning and I wouldn't didn't
have a body it was just like a ball like
the size of a pingpong ball I turned and
looked and there was this big bright
light it was like a big round welding
Arc just pure white and it came down and
got
me it was I didn't have a tunnel
experience or anything I'm going down a
tunnel not really it was like this ball
came down and got me and then I was in
it and it was just this big [__] ball
this B this big [__] white sea 360
degrees in every direction forever of
like welding Arc is what it was like
Prismatic white pure white light and it
felt like this joyous singing and [__]
everywhere and then out of that stuff
Joy singing and [__] yeah Joy singing as
[__] and then there was like a whole
[__] group of these
[__] like a welcoming committee man I
think there's about six or seven of them
and I knew who they were and they looked
3D like 3D statues made out of that same
welding Arc material there's no way to
describe it because there's no way to
have Shadow or shading but it was just
like imagine 3D figures coming up out of
Television static it was like that but
it was like Prismatic welding Arc and
there was all these people that [__]
were like six of them that were that
were [__] welcoming me back and
[__] I was like oh I hadn't seen you
in a long time that kind of [__] you
know and I remembered how some of them
looked and then they kind of parted and
there was this big tall one and uh I I
knew it I knew who he was and everything
and and he was basically it was kind of
telepathic communication I was seeing
images and emotions I could kind of hear
voice the tone of the voice with it but
I knew it wasn't voices that was just
kind of like a special effect what it
was it was just kind of
thoughts and it and it said uh you can't
stay you have to go
back and I was like no I don't want to
go back man what are you talking about
like this is awesome yeah this yeah I
Ain going back I'm done like no go back
you got to go back CU you have to do
this and this and it showed me stuff
that I had to do and I was like oh yeah
yeah I forgot that I had to do that
as if I had chosen the life and had to
do all this stuff right so like time
like the the timeline didn't really like
everything was kind of oh yeah I forgot
about that yeah you know it's like
remember you have to do this and this
and that oh yeah yeah and I was like oh
yeah that's right so so I got to go back
then she goes yeah you're going to be
all right
basically and um and and he goes
uh and I I said am I going to remember
any of this he because you're going to
remember some of this but some of this
you're not going to be you you're not
going to remember so the things like the
future [__] like you can't remember I
couldn't know yeah well because maybe
it's kind of a thing where it's just
kind of like well we can't sh because
then you might be able to alter it right
right right sure was like we can't spoil
the end of the movie
right basically what it was we can't
spoil the end of the movie that you
chose to
see so then said you got to go
back so said I'm out of here I'm saying
goodbye to them all and I [__] turn
around and look and there's just this
black empty space
with this disc it looked like the damn
Wheel of Fortune you know what I'm
talking about like a flat disc and it
was spinning
slowly and I was trying to figure out
what color it was It was kind of all
colors and it was these threads all kind
of interwoven and this and that and I
realized what I was looking at was
basically the SpaceTime
Continuum and I said where do I have to
go back and then I was kind of my eyes
kind of but I did have eyes I don't
think I did I kind of homed in on where
it was I had to go back to in space and
time and I and I just started going that
direction just automatically and as I
was going to it it was getting
bigger and I was noticing more and more
threads were appearing and they were
individual timelines of other people
other words their life experiences like
I said you would probably like we World
by I saw mine I saw mine it says okay
that's where I was and [__] went in
there and boom then then I was in a
hospital and it was and I remember
sliding
across the across the air next to the
bed for a little while that there was
all kinds of weird [__] those fighting
things there were things in there like
demon type things but then that kind of
went away and then uh just started to
come back to normal but there was it was
weird weird it does sound but no it was
but it seemed more real than reality it
was like hyper
realism kind of unrestricted by the
physical body and it was happening
outside of
SpaceTime well I went through that nde
it kind of reminded me a lot of the OB
that I had had a few days before I was
like this is why that
happened and I know that that did happen
because it happened in the barracks and
my roommate saw it and it scared the
[__] out of
him because uh there was although he
would never tell you exactly what he saw
tell me exactly what he saw I know parts
of what he saw but he wouldn't tell me
exactly what he
saw but where the implication is that he
probably saw you outside of your body in
some fashion I don't think it was my
physical form no no no that's not what I
meant I meant he had a sense that I was
he understood that you were not in your
body yeah he thought I was dead he was
trying to shake me back
awake and I said I says I was up there
did you see me and he [__] slapped my
hand don't you ever ever [__] talk I
says what did you see up there I think
he just remember how you said Sometimes
you have a feeling of a presence
Somebody's Watching You Yeah I think
that's what he felt I think he saw
anything I think it was invisible but he
felt like a pres coming from that
direction think that's what it was well
like I said I have I'm not a huge you
know um I'm pretty skeptical about that
kind of stuff but it's like a couple of
times in my life I have felt a very very
strong sense of like a presence probably
the strongest I think was at um my
grandmother's old house which wasn't
haunted or nothing like that I never
I've lived there for a long time and I
never felt anything weird weird there
but for some reason I was sitting at the
dining table one day and I felt a very
strong presence of like someone standing
right behind me and that was the first
time i' ever felt of that like literally
I was like somebody standing right
behind me like right now and like I
looked around and there was nobody there
now a lot of people have said was well
my grandfather's ashes were in an n in
the china cabinet like right behind me
but I don't know he had been dead for
several years at that point and it's
just like I didn't get this sense that
it was anyone I knew it was just I felt
like somebody was standing there and I
had never felt like that before I was
just kind I was sure somebody was
standing back there and nobody was um
the might Bowser is here and says
Mammoth Mountain Poltergeist uh talked
about how cool it was and it said it
really messed me up seeing that stuff
from years ago close to home trauma oh
see he's seen it too yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you're new here uh we wrote
a book about Tom's experiences yeah that
he had that he had in the early Uncle
red was still alive then cuz he
remembered more about it than I did he
passed away now but yeah some of some of
that [__] for some reason I didn't allow
myself to remember it um most of the big
stuff I did but then there was some
other stuff that was pretty big that
I I just for some reason kind of refused
to remember it but when he reminded me I
was like oh yeah I forgot about that
like the cars you the the the Matchbox
cars being moved yeah and made patterns
I remembered that when he remembered it
uh there was a couple other ones that he
remembered that I'd forgotten all about
I think I forgot about the knife didn't
I no you remember that that one because
I remember you telling me that
okay oh M Bowser says I'm an old hand
here I'm David June oh okay okay we
remember you yeah you just have a
different name now yeah Mandy said
what's weird is I've always had little
Poltergeist activity in every house to
some extent but my worst one was in my
childhood home like my mom sing a
doppelganger of me stuff moving uh stuff
moving and stuff yeah it's my mom seen
TOA gangers of me too yeah yeah yeah I
was going to say like I think well when
you were in your motorcycle rack she was
in Brazil she was in Brazil and she said
that she saw Tom appearing in the
kitchen yeah and and said hi Mom yeah
it's all happy but she knew that
something was wrong because she knew
that obviously he wasn't there like he
was in another country she called the
Army trying to yeah and she was like
what the [__] is wrong something wrong
with his yeah because just appeared in
my kitchen and said saw image of me but
yeah I remember her tell I remember it
though well yeah but I remember her
telling me that multiple times but um
yeah the I've been hearing a lot about
um it it didn't seem to be like a thing
but like recently I've heard a lot of
stories about people that had like you
know Poltergeist dish type experiences
and there's a lot of doppelganger [__]
involved and honestly like doppelganger
[__] is like really scary to me and I
don't really know why that is I don't
think the doppelganger is there of
course no probably not it's just psychic
contact with the person is so strong
they feel they they they see the image
but it's not there if you had a camera
and tried to video there there'd be
nothing there it's like a a psychic
hallucination I
believe because it wouldn't would
wouldn't be energetically economical to
form some kind of
a 3D image you know what I mean out of
some kind of weird Quantum particles why
not just place that image in someone's
mind that'd be a lot easier yeah it is
probably all probably all it
is but I don't really understand I've
always been like really creeped out by
the whole
doppelganger
concept and I can't really put my finger
on why that is but it's like whenever I
hear a story about yeah you know I was
in the house and like my mom said hey
weren't you just upstairs and like
you're downstairs and like that would
freak me out like to think there was
another one of me like running around
and every time cuz somebody mentioned
David Lynch earlier and how he's really
into transcendental Med meditation which
he is and all of his movies are very
nightmarish very dreamlike he's very
into that organic
subconscious um you know trying to
capture that on film um which I think is
one of the reasons why his movies freak
me out so much because he's very into
that uh doubles you know what I mean
like people being in like two places at
once and all that other kind of stuff
and that kind of [__] has always like
freaked me the [__] out and I can't
really articulate why that is but that's
always been one of the scariest things
to me it's just and I don't know why
that is
but Alex Rivera said Jenny it's because
of that damn Twilight Zone episode it
had that effect on all of us maybe
that's what it was maybe it was just
like from my childhood you know what I
mean yeah Mandy when mine was real
strong you know when I was about 14 and
like I said it was really only really
really strong for about two
weeks it would uh just do things like
make things appear in the center of a
room like a big stack of plates or
something and you don't know how they
got in there they would have passed you
to go through the door you know but
they're in there and that you know like
a teleported in there fast and it would
just you know play games with you um
sometimes it would throw
things mostly it moved things behind
closed doors you could hear you you
could hear it moving things in a room
and you'd have the door closed Clos and
then as you approach the door you could
hear it stopping then you'd open the
door and the furniture would be
rearranged a bit things upside down Lois
saw red and Lois saw some stuff they
were standing at the foot of the bed in
one room where [__] was moving and the
comforter slid off the bed and wrapped
around them and then simultaneously the
[__] little throw pillows [__]
went up over their heads and went on top
of the closet because the closet had a
little cubby hole in there I heard Lois
screaming and I went running to see what
it is that they were seeing by the time
I got to the doorway she was [__] up
on her tippy toes going oh my God oh my
God oh my God I couldn't see what was
happening then she goes it's gone and
she said that she felt something like a
damn cross between a snake and a hand
she couldn't see it but it wrap around
her waist and snake its way down a leg
and go go down into the [__]
floor said it felt like it had a hand on
it said it was kind of cold but you
couldn't see
anything so I don't know just some kind
of psychic motive Force or
something I mean pretty weird and like I
said we've talked about this a lot and
we pretty firmly established that it was
probably coming from you yeah not in the
sense of it being like an entity or
anything it's recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis but it's
subconscious and it kind of has its own
character like a character in your
dream yeah and you know like I said
before we've had minor incidents happen
not so much here but like I said Tom
messaged me two days ago about the
rubber weird rubber band thing yeah but
we had a lot of stuff happen at the
house that we lived in Sanford we've had
some here a little bit Yeah remember
that metal skull ring that that biker
woman came oh yeah yeah that Happ your
other wife I was looking for something
my other
girlfriend wife she's been crumpled up
one shoulder higher than the other she's
how you doing
baby I'm G give it to you at the Oasis
at the Oasis yeah you can have all my
rings she gave me this ring it's a
stainless steel ring she goes that ring
is stainless steel thank you very
much and
uh I've never I had that ring in the uh
up on top of a little [__] cabinet
that I had up there with some like AR-15
uppers and
[__] and I was looking for something
else and as I was going my eyes went
across that thing and I saw that ring
for a second as I looked away I saw it
flick up off the [__] top of the
thing and flutter down like this like a
leaf as I looked away but I wasn't
watching it when it did that it just did
it when I looked away but then I heard
it Bo hit the ground I was like wait
hold on what the [__] was that I it was
weird and it didn't happen when I looked
at it I looked at it and I looked away
when I looked away I saw it in the
corner of my eye go flying up spinning
and then it fluttered down like a leaf
but was fat like I say like a leaf it
was like meant like this
yeah like a zigzag but it was
fast you know but like obviously not
like a metal ring would normally behave
you know in regards to gravity it didn't
move normally it looked like it was in
zero g like it didn't weigh anything all
the weirdest [__] like happens when I'm
not here though that like always I never
get to see anything like I've seen a
couple of things but not anything like
super then she was at work one time this
at the old place I was sitting there I
was [__] jamming out on [__] the
Mad Max video video
game and I was [__] driving and
fighting you know the cars I was zooming
in my reality and a wind came through
and [__] blew the [__] Shades up
and I was like what's the [__] wind
doing in
here it happens real fast you're not
thinking about it you're relax we have
no windows open Jenny seen me do it and
I didn't know that it happened like the
when it threw the remote it took me a
second to go oh yeah I guess it did that
the remote did go flying I'm kind of
like getting zoned out when it
happens and um I saw the [__] in
inner curtains and they never moved but
at the time it didn't it didn't it
didn't startle me it's like they blew in
a big wind and and when they went out
like that they went they they went in
front of that cabinet the same one that
had the ring on top of it and I and I
was looking at the screen but next to it
was that cabinet and I saw something
shoot down at a straight line like a
blur and hit the bottom
[__] uh
shelf and it hit and I heard it go and I
hit paw and looked and it was a little
plastic shot glass used to measure an
E-liquid when you're making your own
E-liquid your own [__] Vape juice
call it juice all
right and it was well inside the [__]
shelves it didn't come out and then go
down and go back in it went straight
down through all those [__] shells
and hit hit bottom first
when like that for a second it was still
settling down when I was looking at it
it was weird and I went and I was like
how'd that wind do that oh that wasn't
wind there's never any wind in here did
you ever see those black drapes [__]
yeah that well like I said have any
windows open or nothing like no we
didn't have anything open now some
people that's [__] you'd be scared
see much worse when I was a kid but it
happens it recently it happens when I'm
almost absent minded I don't know that
it happened I don't realize that it
happened until after it already happened
and the thing about it is like look I
had never seen it I had heard about it
because Tom told me about it like when
we were writing the book yeah but then
you know when we were all sitting in the
living room and you know most of y'all
if you've been here a while like you
know the story but it's me Tom um his
mom was there um also and our friends
Demitri and Jen yeah
trying and we were trying to watch Mad
Max Fury Road we were going to rent it
so we'd already seen it like this is
probably okay this is probably about six
months before the the shot glass when
you say about six month maybe a year
something like that yeah it was a while
before that but it's like so I had never
seen anything like he had told me all
the story so I knew all about it and I
had I think by that point I had written
unseen hand which is you know all about
polter G stuff it had done some stuff
about six months before this but she
didn't see it but I didn't see it it
threw the damn little statues off and
pulled the [__] see I thought that was
after but I I mean I can't really
remember might but so I had never really
seen anything yeah but we used to always
talk about I was like man that I really
want to see it that would be really cool
because I've never seen anything like
super paranormal or anything even though
I was always you know I'm a big skeptic
about it but it's just like man I really
would like to see some of that stuff and
so when it happened and I know people
say it's like oh you'd [__] your pants
or it was scary or something like but it
wasn't like that
it's like it happened in front of our
faces like we were just sitting there
waiting for the movie to start and then
the remote control just picked up and
flew off the table and made like a big
like a big loud sound when it hit the
like like that and then for a
second I wasn't sure I was like did that
did I just see that and like I look at
Demetri and Jan I'm like did you guys
just see that and they're like yeah we
[__] thought like their eyes were
like this big
and so but it wasn't scary like I don't
know I guess because I I was so primed
because I knew it was you and it's just
kind of like so I didn't think it was
like [__] a ghost or demonic or
anything the time I was on the couch
over next to on the other side but it
wasn't scary I just thought it was kind
of neat CU I'd never seen it yeah I was
zoned out on the couch next I was look
on the couch next to everybody else and
I heard the commotion of them going did
you see that thing go fly did you just
see what I just did I just see what I I
looked over there and I was like I was
like what I wasn't really aware I saw it
happen but I just was kind of like it
didn't phase me because I
was I don't want to say any trance but I
was like you how when you stare and
you're kind of like in your own yeah
you're kind doing that when it
happened and uh I looked at that
remote and um I said that came off there
and he went yeah and I stood
up and looked at it and all of a sudden
I felt all the hair standing up on the
back of my
neck and I looked down and there was a
stack of coins at my feet that came from
my [__] bedroom on on the nightstand
and I said look at this and then I went
over there and I took that they were
like wow and [__] Demetri like Tom do
it again and I said no yeah he was very
excited I F I felt the [__] [__] kind
of like building up on me it's kind of
Scar of me and then I uh reached down
and grabbed that remote and threw it
again to see what it sounded like and it
didn't sound anything like it said
remember that it just went click yeah it
just makes click plasticky noise made
like a plastic click noise that was that
wasn't the sound it made the first no it
sounded like like it weighed a [__]
like a brick and it didn't bounce no
stuck either it went yeah like it was
being sucked into the floor yeah it was
like that the reason why the
the the the reason why the [__]
um the coins were there because
sometimes earlier I said she was talking
about remember that I think it might
have been a couple days before or
something we were joking it's like why
can't I do something useful that PO do
something like bring some [__] money
I was thinking at the time like the
money from the bank like a big pallet of
[__] that's what I was imagining
yeah brought me a [__] stack of my
own coins gee thanks yeah that's all
right man bring some else up to like
maybe
75 cheap ass poter guys yeah just gave
you what it here while you're out there
okay here I give something yeah you know
what you know what I want yeah yeah it's
Friday night and I'm free
finally so I'm I'm gonna get [__]
drunk well you know I'm gonna get kind
of
drunk tomorrow we're going to go well
we're going to go and do our uh
stereotypical uh Chinese
buffet and go to the bookstore get some
coffee but last week when we were at the
bookstore it's books a million that has
the Jo mugs Cafe in it in the Lake
Square Mall and I noticed that they're
opening a Spirit Halloween they're
opening a Spirit Halloween right across
from the bookstore in the mall and so
I'm very much hoping that the Spirit
Halloween will be open
tomorrow so I can spend some money in
there I still haven't decided what I'm
going to do for the I can't believe I'm
so behind it's like already September
1st and it's like dude I only have like
two months until Halloween and this is
like way later well okay I've I've
broken it down I'm either going to
do sexy lady werewolf or sexy lady
Predator but I can't I don't know I'll
see what I can come up with I'm not
loving I've already kind of done like a
little bit of a
perun um look around some of the
werewolf stuff that's available I don't
love it but it's like I don't know I
don't have a [__] ton of money to spend
on it I spend a lot of money on my Med
us a costume last year but it kicked ass
so I'm not going to get too upset about
it
but I don't know I can't decide I'm some
days I'm leaning more toward the
werewolf thing and some days I'm leaning
more toward the Predator thing I guess
it will just turn out I mean it'll just
be down to like what is easier to source
and what's not going to cost me like
$500 and [__] like that and what looks
better I don't really know but I do kind
of want to look around if Spirit
Halloween is open it better be open
tomorrow they had all the signs out last
Saturday so I'm kind of hoping that
it'll be open because it's Labor Day
weekend you would think they would open
up so I want to go look and see what
they have in there that maybe I
could use I mean it's easy for you
already know what you're going to do for
Halloween yeah B next year you need to
do M the merciless so that's expensive
costume I know but it's like maybe next
year we can do a whole Flash Gordon yeah
situation
cuz I still want to do what's her name
yeah kala yeah now some people might be
saying how the hell can you move
something with your mind I don't think
you do I don't think there's any kind of
energy or anything involved in it I
would look
at um uh what's his name steuart Hammer
off he's an anesthesiologist who's H
hooked up with a Nobel prize
winning Quantum physic this name uh uh
what's his name Roger Penrose Penrose
sir Roger P sir yeah hi and um look at
it's about Consciousness that
Consciousness is not some kind of
digital computation that there's
quantum physics involved Quantum forces
involved in there and um hammer off says
that if there's quantum entanglement
involved with Consciousness that could
explain a lot of stuff that you hear
from these weird paranormal stories
about like dreaming true and I think I
don't know if you ever mentioned
Poltergeist but I know that that's what
it is it's something like that has to do
with Altered States Of
Consciousness the subconscious can
sometimes do it but there was definitely
seem to be rules one of the rules was is
it doesn't seem to be it seems to be
that the object moved cannot be under
active like no one can be looking
directly at it you can't be looking
directly at it like you can be looking
at it like out of the your
because like I said the whole thing that
happened with that remote control thing
I was like my I was looking in that
direction but I was looking like above
it I wasn't like looking right at it I
just saw it like underneath kind yeah
but I did see it like when it come off
but you know what I mean it was already
in motion when I looked at it yeah
usually when you see the object moving
it's already in motion and it's kind of
coming to rest with by the time you see
it or by the time it's kind of dawning
on you what's happening it happens
fast uh difficult to catch like if you
had a camera in your hand you couldn't
catch
it um for some reason when you're
looking at it you're confirming where
that object is in space and time and it
can't move it that ruins it it it has to
be a the object has to be in a place
that's kind of
like a a a probability or a possibility
so things that aren't being actively
measured or actively observed are kind
of like in a gray area of of the world
of like
maybe and what and whatever part of your
mind that is quantum that's doing this
is in that same state of existence it's
like in in the realm of
maybe somehow it does it but if I tell
you exactly the mechanism I'd be lying I
don't know I don't think anybody and
I've seen it and I don't
know Mandy says off to bed stay spooky I
need a good Halloween costume too I
think dark sea witch ooh I was thinking
about that for a possibility last year
no like not to much I was thinking
either seah hag or like evil
mermaid um which I still might do one of
these days but I was kind of thinking
about I don't know I can't decide if I
want to do werewolf for predator this
year but that's it's one of the things I
want to do but like I said that's if if
Spirit Halloween is open tomorrow I want
to have a look around and see what they
got in there see if there's any
possibilities it's getting late we
should close down too you want some more
food uh uh sure all right which you got
more curry yeah Pumpkin Curry he made
pumpkin and chicken curry I'm going
start heat it up oh my God it's so good
I'll see you guys
later all right Tom's out of here yeah
I'm out so I guess I didn't realize it
was this late I was having such a good
time but um but yeah so it's 10:30 so I
guess we're going to wrap it up we've
been on for three [__] hours have we
really yes we have all right so it's
Friday night it's Labor Day weekend
hopefully you guys have a good 3-day
weekend if you have the days off um you
know so we'll be back
on Monday night talking about a movie I
don't know which one yet because we
haven't decided uh Zach brought up Clute
before and I remember that you kept
bringing that up and we will eventually
get to that movie I CU I see that it's I
think it's on HBO Max which I have so I
might be able to watch that and I have
been wanting to rewatch it so maybe
we'll do that or who knows it just
depends on whatever mood we're in
whenever it come time to watch the movie
so we'll see how it goes on Monday but
hopefully you guys have a good long
weekend thank you everybody for dropping
by and hanging out with us this Friday
evening and we'll see you guys again on
Monday good night